The first thing that tipped the Foundation
off to SCP-087’s presence were the reports
of numerous unexplained disappearances on
campus.
There were plenty of rumors about what might
be behind them, but Field Agents suspected
that the true source of the vanishing would
be something beyond civilian imagination.
All anyone knew for sure was that everyone
who had gone missing was last seen in a certain
administrative building on the university
grounds, and that the disappearances only
seemed to happen when the elevator was out.
The campus was soon flooded with Foundation
agents, creating a barrier
around the administrative
building, and the presumed habitat of SCP
- 087.
Nobody else could get in, and hopefully, whatever
was inside couldn’t get out.
One of the Foundation’s lead scientists
was flown in to consult on the investigation.
What could have been behind all those students
disappearing?
The doctor’s preliminary interviews with
university staff who worked in the building
yielded some interesting details: Strange
noises, like banging and even a faint, shrill
crying, would be heard from a door that lead
to a no longer used stairway in Hallway 3B.
Staff in the building had no reason to ever
take these stairs, especially considering
how many of them reported a strange sense
of unease when just standing outside the door.
The only reason someone might take those stairs
is due to…Elevator malfunctions.
In that instant, the doctor had put it all
together.
The staff they interviewed had their memory
wiped with Amnetics – special chemicals
used by the Foundation with the power to delete
human memories.
The Foundation only used them for staff or
civilians who had confirmed contact with an
SCP, and the doctor knew that they had a live
one on their hands.
The staircase.
There was something terribly wrong with that
staircase, and it was the SCP Foundation’s
job to find out what – before it made anybody
else disappear.
This is the story of SCP – 087, otherwise
known as The Endless Staircase, and the three
doomed journeys down into its murky depths.
The doctor was more than eager to begin research
into the staircase, and its frightening, anomalous
properties.
After all, you don’t claw your way up to
being one of the Foundation’s key researchers
without being brave, and perhaps just a little
bit deranged.
As was standard, once a perimeter was secured
around the staircase, the good doctor requested
a selection of D-Class personnel for testing.
For those not in the know, D-Class is the
Foundation’s polite way of saying “cannon
fodder.”
The doctor was sent three D-Class prisoners
for use in his investigation of SCP – 087.
The first, D-8432, was – according to official
documentation on the incident – a “43-year
old male of average build and appearance and
unremarkable psychological background.”
This man once worked for the Foundation in
a more official capacity, but he was given
the often-deadly demotion to D-Class due to
a dangerous mistake handling SCP – 682 that
lead to the deaths of several other agents.
Now, it looked like it would be his turn.
The doctor explained his mission to him: Explore
the staircase, gather data, help us find out
exactly what we’re dealing with here.
If you come back alive, there may even be
a promotion in it for you.
And with that promise, D-8432 was given his
load-out: a 75-watt flood lamp with battery
power capable of lasting 24 hours, an audio
headset, and a handheld camcorder fitted with
a transmission stream.
D-8432 was then pushed through the door in
Hallway 3B, and out onto the staircase.
According to declassified Foundation files
describing the staircase, “SCP-087 is an
unlit platform staircase.
Stairs descend on a 38-degree angle for 13
steps before reaching a semi-circular platform
of approximately 3 meters in diameter.
Descent direction rotates 180 degrees at each
platform.
The design of SCP-087 limits subjects to a
visual range of approximately 1.5 flights.”
But in D-8432’s mind, “unlit” really
didn’t seem like the right word.
He would have chosen “all-consuming darkness.”
Despite carrying a powerful 75-watt lamp,
D-8432 was only capable of partially lighting
the platform he was standing on – and the
illumination only stretched down nine of the
thirteen steps to the next platform.
When D-8432 observed how little help his lamp
was giving him, he was instructed to shine
it out of the doorway into Hallway 3B.
When he did so, the light seemed to shine
far further than it ever could in SCP – 087.
Already, the beginning of anomalous activity
was obvious: Everywhere else, darkness is
just the absence of light.
In SCP – 087, darkness eats light.
It was like a tangible, black mass that only
a certain amount of light could survive, while
the rest just wouldn’t show.
D-8432 swallowed hard over a lump in his throat.
The door to Hallway 3B was closed behind him,
and he was ordered to descend.
Surviving to see that promotion was feeling
unlikely, but it’s not like he had a choice.
If he tried to escape SCP – 087 before he
was permitted, he’d be shot by SCP Foundation
Field Agents on the spot.
So he followed the high-ranking doctor’s
orders and began to descend the steps to the
next platform.
Nothing about the physical makeup of the staircase
itself seemed abnormal – the base and walls
were a very plain, dull concrete, with a metal
handrail.
The only thing that seemed unique about it
so far was the strange light-bending properties.
That was, until he reached the second platform
down and he heard it, a soft, echoing cry.
A child’s cry.
It was shrieks of panic, or maybe even pain,
echoing up from below.
He was asked why he had stopped, and he explained
the crying sound he’d been hearing.
It sounded like it was coming from far down
the stairs, maybe 200 meters below him.
He could just make out the words “please”,
help”, and “down here” coming from the
darkness.
But the team outside the stairwell couldn’t
hear anything, so they asked him to descend
further.
Another platform down, and they could hear
it too, the unmistakable cries of a terrified
child.
“Please”, “help”, and “down here.”
D-8432 was ordered to keep going and only
stop if he noticed changes
to the visual environment
or in the sounds he was hearing.
D-8432, knowing his life was on the line,
had to keep going, and descended another twenty
flights of stairs before stopping to remark
that the sounds of the child hadn’t gotten
any closer.
They still sounded just as far away as when
he’d first heard them.
He was told his observations were noted, and
pressured to continue.
Within half an hour, D-8432 had descended
a full fifty floors, with no sign of a bottom
in sight.
Somehow the volume of the child’s crying
had remained consistent throughout, as if
it was moving away from D-8432 at the same
rate he was descending.
At this point, D-8432 reported that he was
feeling uneasy.
The doctor said that this was understandable,
given the circumstances.
He’d been watching what little there was
to see over a live video feed the entire time,
and something about the truly bottomless nature
of the staircase, and the ever-elusive crying,
was undeniably eerie.
But things were about to really take a turn
for the worst.
As D-8432 stepped forward towards the next
set of stairs, he froze.
There was something on the platform below
him, barely illuminated by the light of his
75-watt bulb.
It was a face.
Vaguely human in size and shape, but with
a few terrifying differences: it had greyish
skin, and no mouth, nostrils, or pupils.
And yet, D-8432 could feel that this thing
was making eye contact with him.
He couldn’t move, trapped in this thing’s
piercing gaze.
In an instant, the face jerked forwards, suddenly
only about a foot away from D-8432’s face
– eyes staring into his own.
D-8432 screamed and ran, scaling all fifty
flights in an astonishing eighteen minutes,
before charging out into Hallway 3B.
There, he collapsed from the exhaustion and
the fear of what he’d just seen.
Upon reviewing the footage, the strange face
was designated “SCP-087-1.”
Fascinating.
It was time for a second experiment.
The doctor just had to know more.
The second test subject was D-9035, a 28-year-old
male with a history of aggravated assaults
against women.
He was given the same loadout as his predecessor,
except this time with an even more powerful
100-watt bulb.
He was also given 100 small LED lights that
had adhesive backs and a
battery life of approximately
3 weeks, with which they intended to permanently
illuminate SCP – 087.
However, despite the extra wattage of his
bulb, he still couldn’t illuminate beyond
the ninth step.
SCP – 087 wouldn’t allow it.
Having no idea of the horrors that lurked
below him, he descended on the doctor’s
orders, and began fixing the LEDs to walls
of each platform he passed.
The LED always illuminated the landing, but
the light couldn’t pass the first step on
either side.
The flights of stairs themselves would remain
in perpetual darkness.
After the second flight, D-9035 noticed the
same crying D-8432 had heard and became uneasy.
Just like before, as D-9035 descended, the
volume of the crying didn’t seem to increase,
as if for every step he descended, the source
of the crying descended one, too, keeping
them at a constant 200 metres apart.
Still, he was ordered to continue his descent
and the placing of LED’s even as his paranoia
grew.
When he reached the 51s floor, he observed
damage to the wall and steps – sections
appeared to have been smashed to rubble by
an extreme force.
As he descended past the broken step, he only
felt his fear, anxiety, and paranoia grow.
The doctor made a note of the fact that SCP
– 087 seemed to cause instances of anxiety
and terror in its occupants, even before they
encountered SCP – 087 – 1.
As D-9035 reached platform 89 – a full 350
meters under the initial platform – he stopped
dead in his tracks, and saw something staring
up at him from the platform below.
That same terrible, grey face, with those
dead, white eyes.
He was encouraged to stay calm and try to
get better footage of the face, but it charged
for him and D-9035 ran for his life.
He ascended the staircase at a staggering
pace, even passing out from exhaustion and
remaining motionless for 14 minutes half way.
When D-9035 finally gathered the strength
to get up, he scrambled back to Hallway 3B
and fell into a state of catatonia.
He remains unresponsive to all external stimuli
to this day, just staring off into the distance
with a haunted expression.
Almost like he’s still there in the hallway.
The doctor wanted to conduct one more test
before he ordered SCP – 087 shut off from
the world forever, and it was the most terrifying
of all.
The final subject was D-9884, a 23-year-old
woman with a history of depression and the
use of excessive force.
The doctor had hoped that D-9884 would travel
the deepest yet, and so,
he gave her the additional
supplies of a backpack containing 3.75 litres
of water, 15 nutrient bars, and 1 thermal
blanket.
As far as the Foundation was concerned, she
was in this for the long haul.
But none of them had any idea quite how right
they were.
When D-9884 entered SCP – 087, all the lights
from the previous expedition had disappeared.
Still, she was ordered to go deeper.
She heard the crying of the mysterious child
– if it was even a child at all – and
again she was ordered to go deeper.
At the 496th landing, even as D-9884 seemed
to slip into a state of mortal terror, once
again she was ordered to go even deeper.
Every moment, he was hoping to get a better
look at the face of SCP – 087 – 1.
And when D-9884 finally broke, and fled back
upstairs, he did.
The face appeared but this time it was mere
inches behind her, staring directly into the
camera with its blank eyes – startling even
this veteran of the supernatural.
The face appearing caused D-9884 to panic
and flee, but instead of going back up the
stairs to safety, she went deeper down the
staircase in an attempt to escape it.
Deeper, and deeper, and deeper, until her
video feed cut out.
D-9884 was never seen again.
In the aftermath of the tests, the SCP was
classified as Euclid – it may have been
dangerous, but at least it was easy to contain.
The door to Hallway 3B was replaced with one
made out of reinforced steel,
with an electro-release
lock mechanism.
It has been disguised to resemble a janitorial
closet consistent with the rest of the building.
The lock won’t release unless a classified
number of electrical volts are applied, while
the key is turned counter clockwise.
And after a few inches of foam insulation
were applied to the inner side of the door,
staff at the building never again reported
hearing strange noises.
As for the fates of those lost within the
endless turning flights and platforms of SCP
– 087, we may never know.
But one can only assume it isn’t pleasant.
Here we go again. It’s time to return to the
acid-filled containment chamber of SCP-682,
more commonly known as the Hard to Destroy
Reptile. We’ve spoken about him and the ways
The SCP Foundation has attempted to destroy him
in a previous video. But as we said back then,
we really only scratched the surface
of the huge number of insane ways
the Foundation has tried to wipe this
ornery lizard off the face of the earth.
Today, we’re filling in some of the cracks.
Let’s take a look at the secret test logs
detailing the Foundation’s unsuccessful
quest to finally destroy SCP-682. If you’re
a real SCP Expert, you’re likely to recognize
some familiar faces we meet along the way...
Esteemed Foundation Researcher Dr. Alto
Clef - famed for his somewhat unconventional
personality - entered the test chamber to see
if he could intimidate the beast to death. This
resulted in a long staring contest between
Dr. Clef and 682, towards the end of which,
Dr. Clef began to lose his nerve. He
tried to leave the room, only to find
that the door was locked, causing him to swear
loudly. Dr. Clef, who always tries to find the
most direct solution to his problems, blew up
the door with plastic explosives and ran off.
Test failed.
Next came SCP-662, a silver
hand bell that summons the supernaturally helpful
butler, Mr. Deeds. When Mr. Deeds was summoned,
Foundation researchers asked him if he could kill
SCP-682. Deeds politely explained that he wouldn’t
be capable of killing 682, it’s just too strong.
When asked if he could at least incapacitate 682,
he replied that the best way to do this
would be to poison himself and allow 682
to eat his body. But this, he reminded, would
only be a temporary problem for the lizard.
Test failed.
The Foundation brought in SCP-689,
a terrifying soapstone statue of a sitting
skeleton that can kill you if you see it and
then stop paying attention to it. 682 first
observed the statue, and then the Foundation
turned off the lights. When they turned them
back on, SCP-682 appeared to be dead in a
puddle of gray and black liquid. D-Classes were
sent in to confirm that 682 was actually dead,
but it instead got up and killed them. Researchers
theorized that 682’s definition of “life” is
not quite the same as ours, rendering
689’s death-related powers ineffective.
Test failed.
SCP-807 was next up to bat. This is
an anomalous salmon-colored ceramic
dinner plate with the words "Last Chance
Diner" printed on the edges in white. Any
food placed on it becomes irresistible by any
definition, but when the food is consumed it
causes immediate cardiac arrest due to the
sudden clogging of the arteries with fat.
Researchers made a meal known as the
“682 Special” - 10 kg of rotten meat
and sharpened bone splinters, 10 L of
rancid mayonnaise, 1 L potassium cyanide,
and 1 kg morphine hydrochloride,
combined into a solid mass and
transmuted by 807. When 682 first consumed
this disgusting meal, it seemed to collapse.
However, when D-Classes were sent in to see
whether 682 was truly out for the count,
multiple holes opened in its body. These
holes fired out high-pressure jets of blood,
killing the nearby D-Classes and destroying
the containment cell. 682 was fine afterwards.
Test failed.
To kill 682,
it seemed that the Foundation really needed
to have God on their side. So they tried to
recruit SCP-343, also known as “God”, to
help them destroy the beast. However, when
he entered the containment chamber, he somehow
couldn’t even see the beast. When researchers
asked him whether he could kill 682, God replied,
“He's not one of mine. Deal with him yourself."
Test failed.
Next, the Foundation recruited SCP-524: A small
white rabbit that can eat literally anything,
including itself, without being harmed. The
rabbit was released into SCP-682’s chamber,
at which point it approached 682 and began to
eat one of its legs. 682 roared in pain and
scuttled up the wall, out of 524’s reach, where
it remained for a number of hours. At this point,
SCP-524 seemed to become bored, and began eating
its way out of containment through a nearby wall.
Test failed.
Maybe the luck of the Irish was what
the Foundation needed to finally put
this monster to rest. They recruited SCP-1933,
a fat man dressed as Santa Claus whose bodily
fluids are entirely the alcoholic beverage known
as Irish Cream. However, if enough of this Irish
cream is fed to something, all of their bodily
fluids will become Irish cream, killing them.
The Foundation fed large quantities of this
Irish cream to SCP-682. At first, it appeared
intoxicated, a promising sign. However, it vomited
out a massive quantity of SCP-1933 bodily fluids,
turning the walls of its cell into Irish cream
and allowing it to escape and wreak havoc.
Test failed.
The Foundation recruited the help of SCP-2337,
an intelligent corn crake known as Dr. Spanko,
with a voice so loud it can quite literally
talk its victims to death if it speaks to them
for an extended period of time. It was sent
into SCP-682’s chamber to destroy the beast,
but 682 just told it to leave, and the
talkative bird obliged - by blowing
away one of the chamber walls with a yell,
allowing SCP-682 to breach containment again.
Test failed.
As you can probably sympathize with right now,
the Foundation researchers were starting to get a
little frustrated with their lack of progress.
They even pitched the possibility of sending
SCP-682 into an alternate dimension, perhaps
into a stalemate against its alternate self.
But this pitch was shot down by the O5 Council on
the grounds that it was way, way, way too risky.
Back to the drawing board. By which we
mean, they literally transformed SCP-682’s
skin into a kind of drawing board.
SCP-2521 is an anomaly that manifests
any time information about it is recorded, and
immediately grabs the source of the information,
wrapping it in its tendrils and taking
it away with it. The Foundation sought
to take advantage of this by using a laser to
cut this anomalous information into SCP-682’s
side. However, this didn’t have the
results that they were hoping for.
SCP-2521 did turn up to take the
information, but it only took the
skin on which the information was carved.
682 survived and quickly grew back its skin.
Test failed.
Researchers suggested tracking down SCP-169,
an obscenely massive underwater creature known
as The Leviathan, and feeding 682 to the beast.
However, this idea was immediately shot down
by the O5 Council. If 682 did what it did best:
Surviving the attack and acting accordingly,
perhaps by growing to the size of SCP-169,
it would likely trigger an XK-Class End of the
World Scenario. It simply was not worth the risk.
The Foundation released two specimens of SCP-939
into 682’s test chamber. These voice-imitating,
amnesia-inducing monsters have
caused huge damage to human targets,
so maybe they had some hope against 682.
This hope turned out to be misplaced:
Both specimens seemed extremely distressed by
682’s presence and refused to engage. 682 did not
have that same refusal. It charged in and brutally
killed both, before devouring their corpses.
Test failed.
In a very well-documented case, the adorable
SCP-999 was introduced into 682’s test chamber.
The unassailable good vibes provided by 999,
as well as an intense tickle fight, did actually
lead to the temporary incapacitation of SCP-682.
However, the otherwise wholesome incident ended in
tragedy when 682 adapted to the good vibes and was
able to release a kind of violent laughter
wave. This incapacitated much of the staff
and allowed 682 to breach containment and go on
another killing spree, before being recontained.
Test, once again, failed.
One of the closest attempts the
Foundation ever had involved SCP-294,
an anomalous coffee machine that can
produce any liquid typed into its keypad.
Foundation researchers requested “SCP-682
Killer” from the machine, and were astounded
at the results. During tests on SCP-682 tissue
samples, the liquid was capable of causing 682
tissue to decay and crumble. Tests on the living
creature were similarly promising. The acid in
682’s tank was receded, and one liter of SCP-682
Killer was poured onto it, causing that portion
of its flesh to immediately decay. When the acid
was returned, this portion dissolved instantly.
Scientists believe that if they could one day
get a large enough quantity of this liquid,
they might have a viable option.
But until then, the tests march on.
They introduced SCP-055, the self-keeping
secret, into the containment chamber of
SCP-682. We don’t really know what happened,
but seeing as 682 isn’t dead, we now know that
055 can’t kill it. That and the fact it isn’t
round is pretty much all we know about SCP-055.
Test failed.
Next came SCP-082, also known as Fernand the
Cannibal. Fernand was first presented a piece
of flesh from 682, but rather than eating
it, he inspected it and began to express
joy that his “friend” still lived. When
introduced into 682’s testing chamber,
Fernand attempted to subdue the lizard
and use it as his steed. 682 expressed
an intense hatred of both Fernand and the
idea of being Fernand’s steed, so the two of
them engaged in combat. Mobile Task Forces were
eventually brought in to subdue both subjects.
In the debrief interview, both hinted
that the two of them shared history
prior to containment. 682 was
reluctant to talk about it.
Test failed.
Researchers were becoming extremely frustrated
with SCP-682’s unwillingness to die, so they
called in an SCP who responded
to reason much better: SCP-049,
the Plague Doctor. This sinister surgeon can
kill with a touch, and the Foundation hoped
that would extend to 682. However, the result
was a dud. The Plague Doctor did touch 682,
but it experienced no adverse effects, and
even swiped at the doctor. Upon leaving,
049 reported feeling “emotionally
disturbed” by his encounter with SCP-682.
Yep, you guessed it: Test failed.
If it gives you any indication of just how
desperate the researchers were at this point,
Dr. Richard Graham pondered whether introducing
SCP-682 to a human with just as pessimistic and
misanthropic feelings as itself would somehow
pacify it. They sent in a particularly nasty
D-Class, and the two spoke. Fascinatingly,
682 didn’t attempt to harm this D-Class,
they just shared their profane and bleak
sentiments about the human race with one another.
However, some of 682’s opinions were a
little too spicy for this D-Class. After
listening to the reptile speak for twenty
minutes, the D-Class fell into a catatonic
state from the sheer depression
of it all. He died not long after.
One anonymous researcher suggested
perhaps the worst idea of all:
Letting SCP-682 out into the wild. Not even to
really terminate it, just to see what it does.
The anonymous scientist figured there would be
some merit in analyzing the creature’s behavior.
As you can probably guess, this
request was shot down by the O5
Council. The note attached to the request
by one of its members summed it up best:
“I'll tell you what it'll do. It'll go out for
a nice stroll, murder a few innocent people,
go fishing, slaughter a few more innocent people,
start up a tech-company, eat a few more innocent
people, go on a vacation to Florida, dismember a
few more innocent people! I swear, when I find out
who wrote this, you can personally enter 682's
containment chamber to analyze him yourself!”
Over fifty men and women, clad in red robes,
kneel before an unholy altar.
They chant and mutter indecipherable words
- words of cruelty and madness… of obsession
and sacrilege.
Not long ago, these were regular people.
Computer technicians, teachers, plumbers,
construction workers, accountants.
This was before they fell under the ungodly
influence of a new ruler.
The center of this makeshift place of worship
was once a normal school gymnasium, but it’s
now the home of a huge statue.
A humanoid being, wreathed in tentacles.
Its head is more like a squid or cuttlefish
than anything resembling an actual human face.
While he’s known to the cultists as the
Tentacled God, the beast they worship is known
to the SCP Foundation as SCP - 2662, and he
sits in the belly of one of their expansive
containment facilities, locked away from the
world.
But not for long, if his devoted followers
have anything to say about it.
This is their god, all-powerful and unchanging,
and when it comes to springing
him from containment,
no tactic is too vile or underhanded to get
the job done.
Their mortal leader and high-priest, a man
in a purple robe calling himself Brother Marsh,
walks among their crouched forms.
He whispers instructions for the great day
of liberation that’s soon to come, providing
everyone plays their part.
It’s a plan months in the making - and one
that, if it goes off without a hitch, could
free their monstrous god into the world.
They would strike at the very heart of their
enemy, The SCP Foundation, when they least
expect it, and nothing shall stand in their
way.
How could they lose when they have a god on
their side?
But why did all these normal people become
violent zealots for squid-faced deity?
It all began with a dream.
To those who experienced these dreams, they
felt more like prophecies, premonitions of
the glorious horrors to come.
A red sky, billions dead and billions more
enslaved.
A dark silhouette on the horizon - Their Tentacled
God, holding dominion over all.
At first, it just seemed like a strange nightmare.
The ones who experienced it woke up shaken
and afraid, hoping to shake the images from
their mind.
But they couldn’t.
Every night, the nightmare would return.
They’d see the images - the red sky, the
dead and enslaved, the Tentacled God.
And after a while it would come to them even
when they weren’t asleep, eventually happening
whenever they closed their eyes.
Little by little, this scene stopped looking
so hideous… and started to look glorious.
They felt his presence in their minds, slowly
pushing them towards their inevitable future.
They started to realize that they wanted him
to rule over the universe, and to experience
the honor of serving him.
Many of them abandoned their homes and families
- leaving their friends and loved ones left
to worry that they’d gone insane.
In their eyes, they were safer than they’d
ever been.
They finally had purpose.
They were working in service of something
far greater than themselves.
The influence of the tentacled god drew them
closer to one another.
They would meet in secret, exchanging information
from the prophecies their ruler sent them
in their dreams.
They worshipped together, building altars
and idols to congregate around.
They performed dark blood rituals, involving
human and animal sacrifice.
It was when Brother Marsh, The Anointed One,
arrived to guide them towards their true mission
that things kicked into high gear.
Just three months prior, Brother Marsh had
been an office drone working in data entry
for a large insurance company, before the
Tentacled God invaded his thoughts with a
simple message: “FREE ME, AND THE NEW WORLD
I CREATE SHALL BE YOUR PLAYGROUND.”
Since then, he’d devoted himself completely
to the cause, quitting his job and maxing
out his credit cards to help fund his new
life’s purpose - infiltrating the SCP Foundation,
and releasing his inhuman
ruler from its imprisonment.
That was the single goal he united the cultists
under: Freedom for the Tentacled God.
And at long last, they had all the pieces
in place to strike.
They’d finally gathered the necessary intel
to subvert the will of the most powerful secret
organization on earth.
Even the strongest institution is made of
people, and people are weak.
Unlike the almighty Tentacled God, people
could be broken.
The people in question were Kelly Thompson,
Sidney Levitt, Jordan Brosh, Dr. Juan Gutierrez,
and Gillian Larson.
Dr. Juan Gutierrez was a researcher with Level
3 clearance on the site where the Tentacled
God was being contained.
Sidney Levitt and Jordan Brosh were both Security
Officers charged with verifying personnel
clearance on site.
Kelly Thompson was a member of Site Administration
with research authorization powers, and Gillian
Larson was a research assistant who often
collaborated with Dr. Gutierrez.
These five were the key to getting access
to SCP-2662 and bringing their plan to fruition.
Normally, personnel dossiers on people working
for the Foundation were highly confidential,
but the Devotees of the Tentacled God had
their ways.
They had a number of computer experts in their
ranks more than capable of hacking in and
pulling some basic information off of Foundation
servers without being detected.
For the other information they needed they
turned to some good, old-fashioned torture,
which is often the most effective method when
you need some quick results.
Of course, while the cult’s grip on sanity
may have been a little tenuous, they weren’t
stupid.
While gathering their intel, they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were up
against.
SCP-2662 was being held in a humanoid containment
cell, and guarded by on-site Task Force TAU-9,
better known as the “Belligerent Bodyguards.”
These aren’t lazy, donut-chomping mall cops
- these are a heavily trained, heavily armed
fighting force.
Though the cultists had one thing that these
Foundation soldiers didn’t: The element
of surprise.
For everything to go off perfectly, Brother
Marsh’s plans would have to be executed
within a single day, and they were already
on the clock.
TAU-9 had been charged with tracking down
any new SCP - 2662 cults and dismantling them,
and Brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the Foundation tracked
them down and did the same to them.
If they wanted any chance of freeing the Tentacled
God, then they needed to strike quickly and
with overwhelming force.
The SCP-2662 worshippers were able to secure
the addresses of the five
key Foundation personnel,
and station members outside
each of them - including
one who could realistically imitate each.
They waited for night to fall, and broke into
each of their homes as they slept.
What followed was a sequence of ruthless and
efficient murders done in the cause of freeing
their god.
Dr. Gutierrez was shot in the head while he
slept.
Sidney Levitt and Jordan Brosh were both stabbed
to death before either even realized what
was happening.
Thompson, who’d gotten up to use the bathroom,
went down in a hail of machine gun fire.
Gillian Larson had seen that masked figures
were breaking into her home and attempted
to flee, but was caught and beaten to death
by cultists in her hallway.
It was a strange irony that people whose day
jobs entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies imaginable
were murdered in their homes by nothing more
than regular humans.
So far, Brother Marsh’s plan had gone perfectly,
with all five key personnel murdered within
a two minute period.
Next, the selected doppelgängers stole clothes
from their victims’ closets and were handed
the correct forged documentation.
The next morning, each replacement began their
journeys to the site where the Tentacled God
was being contained, while the rest of the
cult armed themselves in preparation for their
own part in the plan.
Nobody at the Foundation seemed to notice
anything amiss when the five arrived on site.
When you work for the SCP Foundation, more
mental energy is devoted to following the
rules that keep you alive than to memorizing
the faces of all your co-workers and each
one slipped neatly into position, disappearing
into the familiarity of office life.
But, infiltrating the site was one thing,
getting past the Belligerent Bodyguards and
into the cell of the Tentacled God would be
another thing entirely.
That’s where the rest of the cult would
come into play.
Heavily armed with whatever firearms they
could get their hands on, the rest of the
Devotees of the Tentacled God - Brother Marsh
included - would attack the containment site
head-on.
In the ensuing chaos, the five cultists who
had already infiltrated the site could take
advantage of the distraction, and break into
the containment chamber.
It was perfect.
They’d launch their attack from the outside…
and from within.
When Brother Marsh declared that the time
was right, the assault began.
A legion of gun-wielding cultists seemed to
spring out of nowhere and started shooting
up the warehouse that was a front for the
containment site.
The site quickly mobilized guards and task
force members to take on the sudden threat,
and just as Brother Marsh had anticipated,
the Site Director called on the majority of
TAU-9 to help repel the violent cultists from
their perimeter.
TAU-9 obeyed, leaving three task force members
behind to guard SCP - 2662’s containment
chamber.
They expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an audience
with their god.
What they didn’t expect was a group of five
Foundation employees walking right up to them
and opening fire, killing two TAU-9 members
and taking the third as a hostage.
While the war was being waged outside, the
infiltrators had found the Tentacled God’s
containment cell in the low-risk humanoid
ward.
Their hostage insisted that using him wouldn’t
give them any leverage - the rest of his team
would neutralize the whole group, him included,
if that’s what it took to stop them.
The infiltrators explained that using him
as leverage was never their intention - he
wasn’t a hostage at all.
He was a sacrifice.
The cultists of the Tentacled God detonated
explosives, creating a hole in the wall and
finally giving them access to their deity.
They climbed through and gazed upon him in
awe.
There stood SCP-2662, twice as tall as a regular
man, with ten huge tentacles emerging from
its back.
In their months of envisioning this creature,
they’d pictured it sitting on a throne made
of thousands of human bones, ready to dictate
its commands to the obedient liberators.
What they certainly didn’t expect was to
see the Tentacled God hunched over a computer
screen.
Still, gods work in mysterious ways, so they
stuck to the plan and began chanting.
They pulled out a sacrificial dagger, and
began sacrificing their captured TAU-9 member.
It was at this point that SCP - 2662 turned
and saw what they were doing with a look of
pure horror.
He rose up from his computer, his headphones
getting caught as he did so.
He told them to go away, that he didn’t
want them here, and that them murdering people
in his bedroom like this was inconsiderate
and disgusting.
The cultists became even more confused - why
wasn’t their god accepting their offerings?
What were they doing wrong?
They tried more chanting, and painting arcane
symbols on the floor in blood, but this just
seemed to make the creature angrier.
He told them, in a tone more fitting for a
teenage boy than a Lovecraftian God, to just
leave him alone so he could play his video
games.
This was seriously not cool!
The cultists were baffled.
They told the Tentacled God they were there
to free him.
He replied that he didn’t need saving.
That crazy stalkers like them were why he
turned himself in to the Foundation in the
first place!
Before the cultist infiltrators could get
another word in, the remaining members of
TAU-9 stormed into the containment cell and
gunned them down with surgical precision.
The war outside was already over - Brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were all
killed in the firefight.
TAU-9 didn’t look the least bit surprised
upon entering 2662’s cell, this was a common
occurrence unfortunately.
They had to deal with an attempted cult invasion
every few months, because SCP-2662’s main
anomalous ability is inspiring violent cults
who relentlessly track down and worship it
with arcane and bloodthirsty rituals.
The problem is, 2662 doesn’t do this consciously,
and definitely doesn’t like the results.
That’s why he’s under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him amused
with video games and reading material while
fending off the deranged cults who try to
invade and abduct him.
Following the termination of The Devotees
of the Tentacled God, just one of many cults
who’d broken into 2662’s containment cell,
the remaining TAU-9 members apologized to
the tentacled creature for the disturbance,
allowing him to return to his gaming.
They assured him that it’d probably be at
least a few more months before something like
this happened again.
SCP-2662’s cell was repaired, and the Foundation
returned to its task of seeking out would-be
cultist emancipators, because for the SCP
Foundation, it’s not always about the anomaly
that’s being kept in containment, but what’s
being kept out.
It goes without saying that the SCP Foundation
archives are filled with some terrifying monsters.
Even the deadliest creatures can, in theory,
be defeated, or at least soundly avoided.
After all, they’re just flesh and blood
- or in some cases, metal or concrete.
But what if reality as you know it one day
just…broke.
Or worse, you were transported to a reality
so frightening and alien to our own that death
seemed like the only escape – but you couldn’t
even give yourself that.
This brings us to today’s topic – the
terrifying alternate reality of SCP – 3001.
The Foundation is no stranger to freaky alternate
dimensions, but what was experienced by joint-lead
researcher Dr. Robert Scranton at Site 120
is a truly unique nightmare.
Co-managed by his wife, Dr. Anna Lang, Site
120 is a facility largely designed for research
into SCPs with dangerous
reality-warping capabilities
in order to mitigate future containment breaches.
Reality warpers are among some of the more
perplexing and dangerous SCPs, from the pocket
dimension-creating SCP – 106 to the SCP-creating
Doctor Wondertainment, and everything in between.
Scranton and Lang’s goal to further study
such entities was an admirable one, if a little
over-ambitious, and on January 2nd, 2000,
during the testing of a new technology created
by the Foundation’s leading power couple,
disaster finally struck.
Scranton and Lang had already been the brains
behind one of the Foundation’s most valuable
tools in the fight against reality-bending
SCPs: The Scranton Reality Anchors.
Their follow up, the Lang-Scranton Stabilizer
– or LSS – likely would have been an even
more advanced variant of their earlier invention
and should have been a huge success for the
team.
But things didn’t turn out that way…
Dr. Scranton and several other researchers
were gathered in Reality Lab A performing
routine tests on the LSS prototypes.
While other technicians ran diagnostics tests,
Scranton stood at the control panel, the blinking
red light above the console confirming that
everything was going according to plan.
But as anyone who’s fallen victim to one
of the Foundation’s many anomalies will
tell you, just because you’ve done everything
correctly doesn’t mean you’re safe.
Scranton began operating the machine, not
knowing that something was rumbling up towards
him from below.
Without warning, a sudden, unexpected burst
of seismic activity rocked the entire base.
Researchers grabbed onto whatever was closest
as the world shook around them.
In his panic, Dr. Scranton clung to the LSS
control panel as the seismic blast fried the
circuits and kicked it into overdrive.
There was a blast of magnificent, blinding
light, and when the rumbling stopped not only
was the doctor gone, he had been erased from
reality as we know it.
The earthquake had caused a deadly malfunction
in the machine meant to stabilize reality,
and instead tore a rift in it, dragging the
unfortunate doctor and the control panel into
oblivion.
His wife, Dr. Lang, and the many researchers
who idolized him were devastated by his unexpected
demise at the hand of what should have been
his crowning achievement.
The one silver lining was
that this reality-ripping
event had almost definitely eliminated the
doctor quickly and painlessly.
As far as The Foundation and his loved ones
were concerned, Scranton’s death had been
immediate and complete – a luxury afforded
to few Foundation employees who die anomalous
deaths.
But sadly that isn’t how Dr. Scranton’s
story – or the story of SCP – 3001 – ends.
No, this is where it all begins.
How do we know all this?
In the hellish new place where Scranton had
been transported, the control panel from the
LSS that he’d been clinging to for dear
life had been transported with him, and continued
to record audio data from this anomalous location.
Not that Dr. Scranton realized it, not at
first, anyway.
As far as he knew, he’d suddenly been transported
into a pitch-black location.
No sights, no sounds, no scents.
True nothingness.
At first, the doctor was confused.
One second, he was testing out his new technology,
and the next he was quite literally nowhere.
In spite of his current situation, the doctor
was still an intelligent and rational man.
He took a moment to compose himself, hoping
that in time his eyes would adjust to the
new darkness around him.
But that moment never came: The darkness remained
perfectly absolute.
Much like the darkness in another reality-defying
SCP, the deadly endless staircase known as
SCP – 087, the dark seemed thick, almost
like you could touch it.
The doctor, not wanting to give himself to
despair and die in this impossible place,
and with no other options seemingly available,
began walking.
Either he’d find his way out, or the Foundation
would find him.
No need to panic.
It may have altered the doctor’s temperament
if he knew that the Foundation already assumed
he was dead, and that no search party was
going to come looking for him.
Still, logic dictates that if a person walks
for long enough, they’re bound to find something.
The problem Scranton was about to face was
that SCP – 3001 doesn’t run by any kind
of conventional logic.
He walked and walked and walked, but he didn’t
seem to get any nearer to or farther from
anything but how could even know?
After all, in total darkness, there aren’t
any landmarks to assist in navigation.
The doctor walked and paced and screamed for
days on end, but he made no progress.
He was alone in an empty world.
He had no choice though, so he kept walking,
and walking, and walking.
For eleven days.
During that time, he felt his hunger and thirst
grow.
He was in terrible pain from a mix of starvation
and dehydration, but the release of death
didn’t seem to come for him.
He was going to have to learn the rules of
this new place the hard way, and it grimly
dawned on Dr. Scranton that dying in this
place might not even be the worst possible
outcome.
He paced and repeated facts to himself, hoping
to ground himself in the moment and avoid
the panic that could so easily set in.
“Name, Robert Scranton.
Age, 39.
Birthday, September 19, 1961.
Favorite color, blue.
Favorite song, "Living on a Prayer."
Wife…
Anna…”
Little by little, the words seemed to turn
to nonsense in his mouth as the terror grew.
Just as he felt like he was about to lose
his mind, he noticed something - a small oasis
in the endless darkness of SCP – 3001: The
glowing red light of the LSS control panel.
Where had it come from?
And how was it still recording?
The doctor had no idea, but he was grateful
for any kind of familiarity in the strange
darkness around him.
Perhaps the LSS could be the key to saving
him, or at least figuring out what on earth
was going on here?
Whatever the case, there was no denying that
having the panel here was better than nothing.
At least, when it was found… if it was ever
found, then people would know what had happened
to him.
As the days passed and he
continued to mysteriously
survive, Dr Scranton deduced that one didn’t
need food or water to survive continually
in SCP – 3001.
The location had an anomalous effect on its
inhabitants.
As the days passed and turned to weeks of
wandering in the darkness, Dr. Scranton further
deduced that he was no longer in his home
dimension – this was an entirely separate
pocket dimension, much like the one possessed
by SCP – 106, but featureless.
A perfect, self-contained void.
Now dimly illuminated by the red light of
the panel, Dr. Scranton explored further into
the void around him.
He travelled for months on end, the pain of
his deficiencies growing by the day, but found
he was getting nowhere.
All things considered, he wasn’t even sure
he was moving, or whether reality and the
darkness was swirling around him like a thick
liquid.
Rather than walking on a single flat surface,
he was moving in all directions
across a three-dimensional
plane.
The space-time continuum appeared to be entirely
broken here, where movement is more defined
by the conscious intention to move than any
real geographical repositioning.
Dr. Scranton knew that this place broke every
single one of Kejel's Laws of Reality Parameters,
and from his years working with a plethora
of reality warpers in Site 120, he had a theory
for why this pocket dimension was so strange:
It had an extraordinarily weak Hume field.
Before we get back to Dr. Scranton’s semi-living
nightmare, we need a quick primer on Hume
theory, and why having a weak Hume field is
such a problem.
A Hume is a unit of measurement for the strength
and amount of reality in a given location
or being.
In an area with an incredibly low Hume field
relative to our world, such as SCP – 3001,
universe breaches and anomalous incidences
rise significantly.
At the time of his being trapped there, SCP
– 3001 had the lowest number of Humes in
any recorded environment, making it a phenomenally
anomalous zone.
It was for this reason that starvation and
dehydration never took hold of him despite
causing him great pain, and the worst by far
was yet to come.
Dr. Scranton wasn’t trapped in this dimension
for weeks or even months.
He was trapped in the darkness for years.
And it took a nightmarish toll on his body
and mind.
The small flashing red light on his LSS control
panel became his only friend and as the years
drew on, he would hold entire conversations
with his only source of illumination.
He knew that his days were numbered – if
he didn’t escape dimension within around
three years, the Hume field would diffuse
further, and he would be left in a truly horrific
state.
But based on how little headway he’d made
in the time he’d been there, he didn’t
feel optimistic.
He kept speaking into the recorder, if only
to break the silence and prevent him from
going completely insane.
But even that would only hold it off for so
long.
Alone and talking to himself endlessly in
the darkness, Dr. Scranton could feel his
mind slipping as the confines of the pocket
dimension constricted and his body began to
change.
The low Hume field slowly diffused his physical
matter, destroying the physical integrity
of his body but never being merciful enough
to actually let him die.
In his haunting audio logs, the doctor described
his hands as diffusing and thinning out like
spider webs.
Over time, there was less and less of him,
and what was left wasn’t entirely human.
As Scranton’s Hume level lowered to equalize
with that of SCP – 3001, the lines between
his body and the LSS control console began
to blur in a twisted marriage of warped flesh
and machine.
The Lang-Scranton Stabilizer was anything
but stable.
Before his mind and body became something
else entirely, the doctor still had the presence
of mind to finally realize how he’d come
to be in this terrible place.
The LSS had opened a wormhole known as a Class-C
“Broken Entry” into a paradoxical pocket
dimension between layers of reality, and taken
him through it.
He’d slipped through a crack in reality
into absolute darkness, and now he was stuck
with a fate far worse than death.
How do we know any of this?
Much like the event in the first place, it’s
a total accident.
Testing superior reality-bending technology
almost six years after the disappearance caused
the sudden return of the missing LSS to Site
120’s Reality Labs.
The only trace of Dr. Scranton that it brought
back with it was the blood and viscera that
coated the console, much to the abject horror
of his still grieving wife, Dr. Anna Lang.
To this day, Dr. Scranton, formerly one of
the Foundation’s brightest minds, remains
trapped in the nightmare of SCP – 3001.
His current condition whether the doctor is
still alive after twenty years of being warped
by the low Hume field of 3001’s darkened
confines is still unknown.
But, for the doctor’s own sake, we hope
he’s been dead for quite some time, because
few things on earth are as horrifying as the
alternative…
On an ordinary day in 1991, a young man known
by the initials J.S. went on a hike with four
of his friends on the wooded outskirts of
their small town.
Everything seemed perfectly normal until J.S.
began to feel a strange sense of familiarity,
like he had been in this spot before.
He couldn’t shake this weird feeling, but
thought nothing more of it.
Little did he know that this was a sign of
deadly things to come.
Several hours after first experiencing that
sense of deja vu, J.S. was found by the side
of the road, covered in cuts and scratches,
with his friends nowhere to be found.
This is the story of SCP - 939, an unforgettable
monster that you’ll never remember.
There was no way for J.S. to know that the
unsettling feeling he felt and the horrors
that followed it were the result of an experiment
conducted by the SCP Foundation, an experiment
with deadly unforeseen consequences.
J.S. and his friends were exposed to a substance
known only as AMN-C227 as part of a series
of tests performed by the SCP Foundation intended
to determine the effectiveness of this substance
as a deliberate amnestic.
Dealing with as many mysterious, secret creatures
and objects as they do, the SCP Foundation
has long needed a way to tamper with the memories
of those exposed to the foundation’s various
prisoners and test subjects, and, when the
foundation discovered AMN-C227, it seemed
like it might be perfect for this purpose.
So where did AMN-C227 come from?
Over a year before the incident with J.S.
and his friends, the SCP Foundation captured
SCP-939.
SCP-939 is a species of endothermic predators
that live and hunt in packs.
They are designated Keter class, and regarded
as highly dangerous and hostile to human life.
Native to caves, they have no eyes, translucent
red skin, and stand at an average of 2.2 meters
tall, with an average weight of 250 kg.
They have four limbs, each
ending in three-fingered
claws and a fourth opposable digit resembling
a thumb.
In addition to their sharp claws, their mouths
are filled with red, fang-like teeth that
reach up to 6 cm in length.
In place of their absent eyes,
they have light-sensitive
spots running along their backs, which are
covered in spines believed to detect changes
in air pressure and flow.
In addition to their many other terrifying
attributes, the internal anatomy of SCP-939
poses a biological mystery.
These creatures have no circulatory system
and no digestive tract.
That’s right, in spite of being predators
seemingly acting on a need to feed, they have
no stomach.
Instead, when they eat their food builds up
in their respiratory system until its presence
inhibits function, and then it is regurgitated.
In spite of being a creature that should not,
under any logical conditions, be able to live,
SCP-939 continues to persist, and is even
capable of giving birth to live young after
a gestation period of 12 months.
The SCP Foundation was able to study a litter
of these young that were born in captivity
in September of 1992, though the creatures
remain just as much of a scientific mystery
as they were upon first discovery.
Everything about them seems to defy the logic
of the natural world - which, to be fair,
is really nothing new for the Foundation.
The respiratory system of SCP-939 was found
to exhale small traces of an airborne amnestic
substance, given the name AMN-C227.
This compound blocks the formation of memories
for the duration of exposure to it, plus a
thirty minute period following the exposure,
give or take a few minutes.
It is colorless, odorless, tasteless, and
completely undetectable in the bloodstream
after only 60 minutes.
AMN-C227 was approved for use as a Class C
Amnestic by the SCP Foundation in 1990 following
some initial tests.
However, after one particular incident involving
a young man and his friends, the official
use of AMN-C227 was suspended.
J.S. and three of his four friends were previously
given a dose of AMN-C227, though the details
of why they were given the amnestic have since
been stricken from the record.
Several months after being exposed to AMN-C227,
J.S. and friends went out on their ill-fated
hiking trip.
While hiking, J.S. was suddenly overcome with
a sense of deja vu.
When he mentioned it to his friends, three
of them agreed that they felt it too.
One of the group, another young man - who
had not been exposed to
AMN-C227 - was uncomfortable
and decided to go home.
J.S. and the remaining three members of the
group made the choice to stay in the woods
and try to determine what was triggering the
unusual feeling of familiarity.
As they got closer and closer to a large cave
near the hiking trail, the sense of having
been there before grew stronger and stronger.
Armed with only one flashlight and a foolish
curiosity, the four went inside the cave.
They made their way deeper and deeper into
the darkness, not knowing why they felt this
way or what they might find inside.
None of the group could explain just what
felt so familiar, only that the further they
made their way into the cave, the more pronounced
the feeling became.
It was getting late, and they knew they should
have been afraid to venture so deep into a
cave with only one light source and no knowledge
of what lay inside, but still they pressed
on.
One of the group remarked that they should
turn back, but the others refused to listen.
They wanted to know what they were getting
close to, what was drawing them deeper and
deeper into the cave.
Unfortunately for them, they would get their
answer.
In the heart of the cave was a pack of SCP-939,
waiting patiently for their prey to wander
into their domain.
There are no witnesses to account for what
exactly happened to J.S. and his companions,
but we can reasonably piece the events together
from what happened after.
Once the friends reached the heart of the
cave, the creatures were on them in seconds,
raking them with their sharp claws and biting
with their fangs.
SCP-939 are larger and stronger than most
people, so it was probably not much of a fight.
However, while his friends were being devoured,
J.S. was somehow able to scramble out of the
cave and make his way into the woods in search
of help.
Under the influence of the AMN-C227 that had
built up in the cave from the presence of
the pack of SCP-939, J.S. lost a large portion
of his memory of the event.
He found himself on the side of the highway
late at night, seriously injured and his clothes
ripped.
An officer found him there, and asked him
to stay still and remain calm until an ambulance
could arrive.
J.S. was still in a panic and attempted to
run away from the officer, begging to be released
so that he could get away.
He babbled incoherently about the color red,
screaming over and over again about the “red,”
though when prompted he could not explain
what the “red” he was screaming about
referred to.
His friends were not with him.
Just as the officer managed to calm J.S.,
the ambulance arrived.
Its flashing red lights sent him into another
frenzy, and he attempted to escape custody,
claiming that the red lights were “going
to get” him.
The official police report described J.S.
as perhaps being under the influence of a
powerful hallucinogen.
That he was just having a “bad trip,”
but the SCP foundation knew better.
The foundation conducted an interview with
J.S. about his experience, and determined
that SCP-939 was certainly involved.
As part of their cover-up effort, they strongly
implicated J.S. in the disappearance and death
of his friends.
He was convicted of manslaughter, though the
bodies of his friends were never found.
It is rumored that the SCP Foundation hired
him on a prison work release program, and
that he now works as a member of the janitorial
staff at one of the Foundation’s facilities.
This incident led to the suspension of the
use of AMN-C227, as it revealed some vital
and disturbing information about the compound’s
side effects.
After exposure to AMN-C227, a person who found
themselves exposed to it again would experience
a sense of familiarity, and feel compelled
to investigate the source of this feeling.
Essentially, anyone treated with AMN-C227
and not made aware of the existence - and
danger - of SCP-939 would become a perfect
victim, primed to be attracted to dens of
SCP-939.
It is likely that this side effect is not
a coincidence, but rather a deliberate hunting
tactic designed to attract prey that had somehow
managed to escape.
With no memory of their attack at the hands
of SCP-939, this previous intended prey would
find themselves drawn to the same den or even
a new one, not knowing that they were walking
back into near certain death.
While the SCP foundation suspended the use
of AMN-C227 as a Class C amnestic, they did
recruit a team of SCP field operatives to
take advantage of this side effect.
This team of operatives was
deliberately administered
a dose of AMN-C227 and briefed on its effects,
as well as the dangers of following the feeling
of deja vu should it surface in the field.
These infected officers were essentially used
as bloodhounds, relying on any sense of unusual
familiarity to sniff out new dens of SCP-939
so that they could be captured and contained
by the foundation.
As far as we know, this operation is still
ongoing today.
However, now that the foundation has a sufficient
number of specimens to study, additional dens
of SCP-939 that are discovered are ordered
to be immediately destroyed.
As for the SCP-939 still in captivity?
They are contained in environmentally regulated
and negatively pressurized cells with walls
of reinforced concrete.
The doors to the cells are air-tight to prevent
the leakage of any AMN-C227, and any personnel
that interact with one of the creatures is
required to wear Level C Hazmat gear to avoid
exposure, and follow decontamination procedures
upon exiting the cell.
All SCP-939 have subdermal tracking devices
implanted to find them in the event of escape.
Only one SCP-939 has given birth in the time
that the creatures have been in captivity,
and only one of the litter survived.
Strangely, SCP-939 young look indistinguishable
from human infants, and change their physical
appearance at some yet unknown point as they
age.
If any more offspring are produced, they will
immediately be separated from the parent and
studied.
The SCP foundation has redacted all information
about the location of these creatures or the
incident involving J.S., refusing to reveal
where their natural habitat is.
All that we know is that they are found in
caves in the woods outside of a small town.
It could be any town, even yours.
Sp if you’re ever out hiking, and are struck
with a sudden feeling of deja vu?
Don’t investigate, don’t get curious,
just go home.
It might just save your life.
What’s in a name?
Ancient folklore and fairy tales sometimes
tell of the importance of names, that they
can hold the power to summon or banish.
Whether you buy into the superstition or not,
you’d be unwise to ignore the power a name
can have, especially if you ever dare to venture
into SCP-4000.
Why?
Use your own name too many
times in this extradimensional
forest, and you may find that what walks out
of it isn’t you at all.
At least once a year, the Foundation leads
an expedition into SCP-4000, to explore this
Keter-class dimension.
But if you go down to those woods today, then
you’d better follow the rules.
Remember, the Foundation has implemented these
strict guidelines for your own safety, and
it’s in your best interest to follow them.
First and foremost, when referencing anything
inside SCP-4000, be it a person, place or
thing, you cannot under any circumstances
use names or titles.
Communication is key when exploring SCP-4000,
and making use of specific descriptors will
deter any adverse effects on your journey.
For example, you may want to refer to the
location of SCP-4000 as “the woods where
you need to speak carefully”, an apt description
for such a place.
Of course, there’s a reason the Foundation
doesn’t provide a handy flashcard of alternative
descriptors for any personnel taking part
in the annual mission into SCP-4000.
Nothing found there can be referred to with
any consistent name, so it is perhaps advisable
to look over a thesaurus
and expand your vocabulary
before visiting SCP-4000, as you’ll need
to come up with a lot of different ways to
refer to the people and creatures around you.
But don’t worry, the Foundation will be
able to train you how to properly refer to
SCP-4000 in both written and verbal communication.
In a similar vein, the second rule states
that no personnel member should respond to
their own name while in SCP-4000.
Naturally, you and your fellow expedition
team will not be alone in the forest you find
yourselves in.
The denizens of SCP-4000 are perpetually-mutating
creatures, some appearing to be trustworthy
while others are hostile.
It is for personnel members’ own safety
that no consistent names or titles are used
to refer to each other in conversation.
This has been known to cause personnel returning
from SCP-4000 to experience vivid hallucinations,
and in some instances has led to appearances
of creatures found in SCP-4000 in our world.
Thirdly, when interacting with the lifeforms
residing in SCP-4000, personnel are advised
to accept any gifts that they are offered,
but are warned to, under no circumstances,
consume anything that is given to them while
inside the forest.
Finally, and above all, do not divulge any
name, nickname, codename, alias, or any other
personal designation when interacting with
any native entities, and disregard any designator
that an inhabitant of SCP-4000 attempts to
assign to you.
Personnel must, however, remain courteous
in the presence of any native creature of
SCP-4000, and treat these entities with respect
and formality.
Access to SCP-4000 can only be achieved by
performing Procedure 4000-Halloway, a ritual
requiring a steady flame in an indoor fireplace,
fuelled by only organic kindling.
Personnel are required to combine the powdered
bones of one male lion, one male red fox and
a baleen whale, and cast these into the fire
with a personal possession holding strong
sentimental value to the staff member performing
4000-Halloway.
Next, personnel are to add three feathers
of a bird such as a raven, or crow, and must
respond with the correct counter phrases once
the fire begins to emit a voice.
If these conditions are met, and the correct
responses given, Foundation personnel will
gain access to the entry point of SCP-4000.
If any error is made during the course of
performing Procedure 4000-Halloway, then under
no circumstances should this ritual be repeated.
Staff are urged to apologise for any incorrect
actions, then refrain from engaging in this
procedure in the future.
Should Procedure 4000-Halloway be completed
successfully, Foundation personnel will find
themselves arriving in the access point to
SCP-4000, emerging from the mouth of an old
well in the center of the forest.
Exploration teams sent into SCP-4000 are advised
that this dimension does not adhere to the
laws of physical space that personnel will
be accustomed to.
There is a single, confirmed-safe route that
must be used when traversing the forest of
SCP-4000, a dirt path leading in a circuit
both beginning and terminating at the entry
point.
Previous attempts to map the landscape of
SCP-4000 all confirm that the only way to
safely exit this dimension is to follow the
entire length of this path in one direction,
until eventually returning to the well.
You have been warned, any attempt to travel
back the direction you came will result in
a loss of contact with the rest of the expedition
team.
As mentioned, SCP-4000 is home to a number
of entities, often noted to be undergoing
continuous and dramatic changes in form.
These physiological mutations appear to occur
whenever these creatures are unobserved, making
distinguishing between them difficult.
When questioned about the exact nature of
these changes, the inhabitants of SCP-4000
claim to have no control over them, and express
distress and dissatisfaction when said changes
occur.
Guidelines have been put
in place by the Foundation
regarding the interactions between personnel
and creatures found in the forest, and adhering
to the rules regarding the use of consistent
names and titles remains vitally important.
The native creatures appear semi-humanoid,
and are reported to be highly temperamental.
Should any staff member happen to offend one
of these natives, they may be subjected to
anything from verbal assault, to acts of extreme
physical violence from the SCP-4000 resident.
If any Foundation personnel further question
why there are so many rules when visiting
SCP-4000, then they need look no further than
the discoveries and fate of Dr Eugene Japers,
who during his initial expedition to SCP-4000
in 2005, encountered a humanoid native entity
whose head resembled a rabbit’s.
As the pair shared a polite conversation,
the rabbit-like creature made an enquiry regarding
Dr Japers’ name, asking:
“How is your name?”
Keeping to the rules, Dr Japers did not divulge
any name or other form of title to the creature,
at this time.
However, Japers remained courteous and polite
during this interaction.
The rabbit responded with the following:
“Are you simple?
I'm merely asking how your name is.
My name has smelt of raspberries lately, I
think - or snapdragons, perhaps.
It's so hard to tell these days, but one makes
an effort.”
In his reply, Dr Japers made reference to
his own name as having ‘tasted rather tart
as of late’, before concluding the conversation
with the rabbit entity.
Upon returning to the SCP-4000 forest three
years later, Dr Japers was met with the same
creature, and once again engaged in conversation
with it.
After briefly discussing their previous encounter,
Dr Japers was able to turn their exchange
towards something the rabbit had mentioned
before, about finding it difficult to describe
its own name.
When asked to clarify this point, the rabbit
replied:
“I can only assume it's because of how long
we've been apart - my name and I, that is.
It was a good name, a proud name, I'm fairly
sure.
By this point, though, it's probably decayed
from its former grandeur, if it even still
exists.”
After this mention of its relationship with
its own name, it should be noted that the
rabbit referred to Dr Japers by the title
‘fellow scholar’.
The third and final encounter between Dr Japers
and this entity came in 2013, after the doctor
was sent into SCP-4000 with instructions to
conduct a more thorough interview with the
subject.
It was during their third conversation that
the rabbit-man revealed
details of a long-forgotten
war between human beings and the residents
of SCP-4000.
Apparently these creatures, the ‘Fae’,
do not originate from the forest in which
they now reside, and – according to the
rabbit-man’s claims – were born in our
world.
“Much as it grieves me to say it, we were
betrayed,” the rabbit explained.
“We had fought side-by-side, you know, in
the war against that factory.
We had done nothing but help them, and what
did they do?
They destroyed us.
They took so many of our lives, and all of
our names.
Some of us fled here when the war was just
beginning, but not many.
Not many.
Still, though, I don't hate them.”
It has been assumed by some that the Foundation
was directly involved in whatever may have
wiped out the Fae, causing them to either
retreat or be banished to the forest of SCP-4000.
An additional assumption has been made that
whatever weapons were used on these creatures
is directly responsible for
their constantly-shifting
state, rendering them without their own names
or identities.
Whatever the case may be, it was during their
conversation that Dr Japers, in reference
to their second encounter, referred to himself
as a ‘fellow scholar’ to the rabbit, in
order to coax information from him.
However, in doing so, the doctor had unwittingly
accepted the title that the native entity
had given him.
By mistakenly responding to the name ‘fellow
scholar’, the doctor had broken the rules
of interacting with the creatures of SCP-4000;
an easy mistake, but a costly one.
The doctor would later leave SCP-4000, traversing
the safe path back to the well.
Dr Japers vanished shortly after his exit
from SCP-4000, and his whereabouts are currently
unknown.
The Foundation has made several attempts to
investigate his untimely disappearance, but
to this day he remains missing and the fur
left on the inside of his expedition gear
displayed no strange properties.
The single goal, it would seem, of the creatures
residing in SCP-4000, is the theft of names.
However, this naturally extends far beyond
this dimension’s definition of identity
theft.
Through an unfortunate blunder, Dr Japers
allowed the friendly nature and demeanour
of the rabbit-entity to trick him into accepting
the name ‘fellow scholar’.
By giving Dr Japers a name, the rabbit was
free to steal, not only his name, but his
very identity.
While it is unclear how this transference
is achieved by the creatures, it is due to
the risk of this that the Foundation employs
such strict rules for any research team tasked
with travelling to the forest of SCP-4000.
Make no mistake, names have more power than
we realize, and this is evident in few places
more so than SCP-4000, a pocket dimension
where ever-changing survivors of a forgotten
massacre exist as identities alone.
Remember, a name is a powerful thing whichever
side of the well you find yourself on.
Your name binds you to who you are, but if
your name becomes someone else’s, then what
else of yours becomes theirs too?
It was just a job.
You were meant to be mopping floors and cleaning
toilets at the Johnston Labs and Pharmaceuticals
Research Center for minimum wage.
And you were happy about it, grateful for
any kind of employment - you didn’t even
know that the company signing your checks
was the SCP Foundation, an organization dedicated
to securing and containing
anomalies and protecting
humanity from their negative effects at any
cost.
And today, you’re going to find out exactly
how steep that cost can be.
The Johnston Labs and Pharmaceuticals Research
Center isn’t actually a research center
at all: It’s a Foundation front business,
with a building solely
dedicated to the containment
of a single anomaly: SCP-3280.
But again, you’re just the janitor, it’s
not like they would bother telling you what’s
being contained here.
If it breaks out, you won’t even know what’s
killing you until it’s too late.
It begins, like most classic horror stories,
on a dark and stormy night.
You’re mopping up a silent hallway, whistling
a little tune to yourself, when rain starts
hammering down on the window next to you.
Not long after, you see a bolt of lightning
split the distant sky followed by an immense
thunder crack.
Soon after you hear screaming and panicking
from below.
Frantic footsteps.
Then, the flashing lights and sirens.
You think back to your employee orientation.
These flashing lights and wailing sirens can
only mean one thing: Containment breach.
You run for it, not even knowing what you’re
running from.
You bring your mop and bucket with you, perhaps
just out of habit.
You seek refuge in the only place in the facility
that truly seems to belong to you: The broom
closet.
The alarm blares as you lock yourself in the
You’re shaking with terror and can hear
the screaming of your colleagues.
You hear more noises - running, scrambling,
a wet dripping sound, gunshots, and then…
silence.
All this time, you can’t help but wonder,
“Why isn’t anybody coming to help us?”
After a while, the only thing you can hear
is the rain and the distant thunder.
It’s been hours.
You’ve only managed to stave off dehydration
by drinking the filthy water from the mop
sink.
But at least it seems like the chaos outside
has died down.
Carefully, you open the door and peek out
of the closet.
Darkness, but no detectable movement.
Now’s your chance and you make a break for
it, creeping down the hall.
The dark hallway is suddenly lit up by lightning
and you can see that there are bodies everywhere.
You step over the corpse of Dr. Cawthrone,
one of the few scientists working here who
actually knew your name.
If you can make it to the security office,
you might be able to radio for help, or maybe
access a computer terminal.
On the way to the office you hear another
horrific scream start to echo through the
complex before it’s cut off by a thunderclap.
You have to ignore it though and push on.
When you enter the security room, you see
that the head security officer, Nichols, is
already dead.
His body has been cut open from neck to groin;
gutted.
The anomaly, whatever it is, has already been
here.
You access the computer terminal and open
the file for SCP-3280.
You’re warned that, as Janitorial Staff,
you have Level 0 Clearance, and as a result,
information will be omitted from the files
you access.
It doesn’t matter.
You press on and open up the file.
Both the object class and the description
have been redacted.
You can only see the Special
Containment Procedures.
They dictate that 3280 is to remain contained
at the Johnston Labs and Pharmaceuticals Research
Center until long term Containment Procedures
can be drawn up.
If the entity ever reaches beyond Sub-Level
2, the facility enters full lockdown mode.
Not even information is allowed in or out
of the facility, as this could result in an
XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
In other words, nobody is coming to save you.
The only other information on the page is
a picture of a lightning storm, much like
the one you find yourself in right now.
Lightning flashes in the hall.
You dart around, paranoid, knowing the anomaly
could be anywhere.
All you can hear now is a quiet drip, drip,
drip of blood coming from the body of Security
Officer Nichols.
Whatever this thing had done to him looked
painful.
You try to remember him as he was in life,
and then, a revelation hits you.
A security officer probably has a lot better
clearance than a janitor.
You feel around Nichols’ mutilated torso
until you find his key card.
Thankfully, Nichols was the kind of guy who’d
write his password on the underside of the
card so he wouldn’t forget it.
You easily gain access to the Foundation servers
with his login credentials.
You now have Level 2 Security Clearance.
The terminal gives you the option to view
security footage taken throughout the site.
You’re given access to every camera still
working after the containment breach and the
subsequent carnage.
You select the camera feed for the Second
Floor Barracks.
There, you see Researcher Jenson hanging from
a makeshift noose attached to his bunk.
There’s a puddle underneath his corpse.
You access the feed from the Second Floor
East Wing.
There, you see Doctor Emmanuel stumbling down
a dark corridor.
His movements are oddly listless, like he’s
in a trance.
Suddenly, there’s another flash of lightning
and a crack of thunder.
Doctor Emmanuel clutches his gut in pain and
crumples to the floor.
You access the camera feed from the First
Floor Entrance.
It seems that the whole area is flooded, is
this because of the storm?
In a panic, many lower-tier staff members
had tried to escape, defying the lockdown
protocols in the special containment procedures.
Now, they’re floating face down in the water,
all dead.
You access the camera feed from Sub Level
2, and see another corpse lying in the corner.
He’s wearing an orange jumpsuit - D-Class,
no idea why he was down there.
The only other notable thing in the basement
was a burst pipe, leaking and spraying more
water everywhere.
With trembling fingers, you select the camera
feed for the First Floor Cafeteria.
The whole room is practically underwater - the
only evidence of the massacre that must have
taken place are the fragments of clothing
floating on the surface of the water.
That, and the fleshy, pink slurry forming
at the bottom of the windows.
It reminds you of the gooey meat runoff in
chicken nugget factories.
You close your eyes and try to center yourself.
It’s violent chaos.
Looking at more of it isn’t getting you
anywhere.
Instead, you decide to put those new Level
2 Security Access credentials to good use,
and hop back onto the file for SCP-3280.
You think to yourself, “There has to be
something I can use on here...”
But even as you wait for the file to load,
some part of you knows that time is running
out for you.
Perhaps it’s the stress, or the fear, or
the filthy mop water you drank, but you’re
feeling the pressure start to mount, physically.
Your stomach is beginning to ache.
You can see blurry shapes moving in the corners
of your eyes.
It’s getting harder to focus your vision,
and harder still to quiet the terrified voices
in your mind.
But you can’t get up - not without knowing
what is doing this to you.
The containment class for SCP-3280 is now
declassified.
“Euclid.”
And what’s more, the Special Containment
Procedures have altered, too.
They now explain that every week, a new member
of D-Class personnel is to be deposited into
the entity’s lair in Sub Level 2 through
Subterranean Access Point Gamma.
The D-Class- or more accurately, the sacrifices
- are to be told lies about why exactly they
need to descend to the lowest point in the
facility.
They’re even given a working flashlight
and a defensive nightstick to create the illusion
that the Foundation expects them to ever return
from the depths.
Little do they know, they also have a tiny
transmitter sewn into their jumpsuit.
This broadcasts a frequency that will attract
an eager SCP-3280 to the D-Class’ location,
like a dinner bell only it can hear.
The file specifies that SCP-3280 always prefers
live prey.
“Well, at least that explains the dead D-Class
in Sub Level 2,” you think, hoping that
it’ll somehow overwhelm the dizziness you’re
feeling, or the nagging pain in your gut.
You read on.
Somehow, the file’s tone becomes even more
severe.
It says that failure to maintain the containment
of SCP-3280 will not only trigger a lockdown,
it will always call in the intervention of
two different Mobile Task Forces: MTF Iota-12,
“The Silencers”, and Tau-4, also known
as “Water, Water Everywhere.”
If twelve hours pass from the point of initial
containment breach, and the O5 Council hasn’t
been given the “all clear” signal by one
of these teams, preparation begins for an
imminent XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
Just reading the words sends you into a cold
sweat.
“End of the World?
What on Earth is this creature?”
Finally, you reach the description.
You get to find out what this horrifying entity
actually is.
But the last thing you expect is for the first
sentence in the file to read, “SCP-3280
is a sapient entity composed of a fluid physically
identical to water, capable of traveling roughly
two and a half kilometers per hour.”
It’s water.
It’s literally a living, thinking blob of
water.
As you read on, the concerning details pile
up: Any water that the anomalous SCP-3280
water touches, it integrates into its own
mass.
But any time water is separated from this
mass, it remains anomalous, and continues
to act independently.
When the creature was first discovered, it
was a mere 66.4 liters in volume.
Now, it’s around twenty five hundred.
The water infected by SCP-3280 is hostile
to all humans, and not just in a defensive
manner.
SCP-3280 will actively seek out human prey.
And when it finds them, it forces its mass
into any available bodily orifice, including
the victim’s pores.
This can happen in such a subtle manner that
you may not even notice
yourself being infiltrated.
But below this, the file has a list of symptoms
for those experiencing 3280 infiltration:
loss of motor control,
weakening of the micturition
reflex, visual hallucinations, and abdominal
pain.
As you read the words, your stomach gives
another painful churn.
Almost like something is moving around inside
you.
It’s all coming together.
You read on.
The file states that SCP-3280 is so difficult
to contain because it exhibits claustrophobic
tendencies.
Any time it’s placed inside a container,
whether organic or inorganic, it escapes with
pressurized water jets that travel at over
255 miles per hour.
If the water is inside a human, it may literally
explode out of them, killing them in the process.
Your jittering eyes turn to the gutted body
of Security Officer Nichols.
It all makes sense now.
Everything is becoming clear as the pain in
your stomach builds in its intensity.
The file goes on to say that if ever SCP-3280
escapes Sub Level 2, it may be impossible
to contain again.
If 3280 ever escaped the site proper, it would
indeed cause an XK-Class End of the World
Scenario to unfold, as 3280 merged with our
water cycle and destroyed all of humanity
on a global scale.
It would become truly impossible for anyone
to escape.
You can’t read any more.
The pain in your stomach is unbearable.
You jerk from your seat and stumble out into
the hall, doubled over in agony.
You can feel it pulsing in there.
Fighting its way out.
It must have gotten in through the filthy
mop water you were drinking.
You didn’t even know it, but your fate has
been sealed for hours.
You’ve been a dead man walking.
The hum of pain builds in your ears and renders
you almost deaf.
All you can hear is the patter of rain and
the distant thunder.
You collapse against the glass, feeling the
coolness of it against the skin of your face.
And in that moment, you see the water droplets
on the window pane reverse direction.
They’re slithering up the glass towards
your face in defiance of gravity.
Then, you realize it’s already over, and
not just for you.
SCP-3280 has escaped.
It’s out there, and it’s going to drown
the entire world.
As you collapse to your knees and prepare
to be torn apart from the inside, your final
thought is that at least you won’t be alive
to see it.
Qinghai Lake, the largest lake in China, is
one of the most secure
locations the SCP Foundation
has ever taken control of.
All available military assets have been gathered
at the site, including three of the most elite
Mobile Task Force units with experimental
weaponry.
SCP-4290 must not be allowed to open, and
the site has been surrounded by nuclear mines
and targeted with the Dagaz-Break Orbital
Strike System.
The perimeter cannot be breached, even if
it means the complete annihilation of the
entire area.
This is considered to be an acceptable loss
for the Foundation, since the destruction
that would be caused by taking such an extreme
measure is far from the worst-case scenario
when it comes to SCP-4290.
That’s because the entity contained within
SCP-4290’s site has the potential to create
a true end-of-the-world scenario.
The Foundation, of course, is no stranger
to such situations, and even has a set of
designations for the various types of apocalypses
like CK-Class restructuring scenarios and
ZK-Class “End of Reality” scenarios.
And since dealing with the end of the world
is nothing new for the Foundation, certain
precautions have been taken at the 4290 site.
If containment measures fail, selected Foundation
personnel and civilians will be taken into
nearby emergency shelters that will hopefully
survive the chaos that would occur following
a breach.
And the Foundation assumed that there was
a good chance this plan would have to be used
at some point, since at the time these precautions
were put in place, it was impossible to know
the chance of successful long-term containment.
But just what is the entity that is held within
the site of SCP-4290 that is capable of causing
so much death and destruction on a major scale?
They call it simply…
“The Child”.
No one has ever seen the child.
No one knows what this entity is.
That’s because even setting aside all the
Foundation security, the site itself is still
deeply protected, literally.
Over a hundred feet below the surface of Qinghai
lake, a stunning collection of relics can
be found.
The site is thaumaturgically sealed with eight
massive metal totems made of Beryllium and
Bronze, that resemble armored warriors.
The statues are inscribed with runes and arranged
in a pattern designed to banish the entity
kept there and keep the seal on its prison
closed.
Archaeological evidence indicates that the
site has been there for a very long time,
and it is still active, with the center of
the site periodically emitting bursts of red
light.
But lately, the bursts have suddenly started
getting brighter.
You may be wondering how we know so much about
SCP-4290, and that it’s a site designed
to keep something sealed if it’s been deep
in a lake, quietly doing its job?
The SCP Foundation has access to unusual sources,
including SCP-1726, and it’s from there
that we learned the little we know about SCP-429.
SCP-1726 is a library in China that appears
to only be one floor from the outside, but
on the inside covers over fourteen square
kilometers in area.
It’s full of a seemingly limitless amount
of texts, many of which describe ancient and
lost civilizations, along with some clues
as to what led to the fall of these cultures.
One text revealed the presence of a terrible
and apparently unstoppable enemy.
It was called the Child - but it was anything
but innocent.
When these texts were translated, what Foundation
researchers discovered terrified them.
They described the emergence of a beast with
ten terrible mouths and twenty arms stretched
wide.
It was attacked by an army of warriors, but
they were quickly overwhelmed by what was
described as “torrents of darkness” and
“Dead geometries”.
They were killed, brutally, and the child
used its skeletal fingers to unleash a torrent
of flame.
Every soul in the vicinity was consumed, wax
rained from the sky, and the Child devoured
everything around it for ten days - as the
whole world trembled.
But then something sealed the Child away in
its prison which is now covered by the waters
of Qinghai Lake.
Soon ominous signs began to appear that the
Child would awaken again though.
One day, televisions in the nearby area all
suddenly stopped playing their regular programming
and began to show images of SCP-4290, with
a mysterious voice coming on over the images
saying “Repair the Child’s Locks”.
This became more and more frequent, and the
tone of the voice became more worried, eventually
saying “There is little time left”.
Further investigations of the location revealed
the location of the mysterious mechanism that
kept the chamber sealed, which was designated
as SCP-4290-LOCK.
But how do you repair a device that is eons
old?
And should you even be fixing it when the
one telling you to do it is a mysterious,
disembodied voice that only appears on pirated
television broadcasts?
The Foundation scrambled to find any information
they could, and they were able to find clues
about the history of SCP-4290 referenced in
other texts.
Lost civilizations like the Xia Dynasty, the
Erikeshans, and the ancient Ortothans had
apparently strengthened the seals during their
own reigns, but the most significant findings
indicated a connection to one of the most
terrifying entities the SCP Foundation had
ever contained - and one
of the most unpredictable.
The Daevite Empire.
This mysterious, warlike civilization has
only been known through one source - SCP-140,
a single hardcopy book titled “A Chronicle
of the Daevas”.
This is a strange, anomalous book that is
written in blood and is able to add more pages
spontaneously to itself whenever it comes
in contact with any fluid that can be used
for writing, but seems to especially prefer
human blood.
It recounts the history of this civilization
and their many brutal conquests.
While there was no proof of the Daevas before
this book was found, evidence paralleling
the events written in the book is now being
found in archaeological digs.
More dangerously, as more pages appear in
the book, the events of the Daeva empire are
moving closer to the present day - with them
currently appearing in the book as having
existed until 270 CE.
The Daevas were a bloodthirsty, brutal race
of warriors, but there was one thing even
that apparently even they were afraid of…
The Child.
The Daevas had performed the last successful
ritual of sacrifice needed to strengthen the
lock not long before their currently described
destruction, and the book contained enough
detail to recreate the ritual.
But SCP researchers would find that performing
it would not be for the faint of heart.
The ritual required three human cadavers,
not a problem for an organization that’s
normal day to day operation results in the
loss of multiple lives, and the live heart
of an angel.
The description of the ritual said that the
materials would be presented, new runes should
be carved into the totems, the items would
then vanish when the ritual was completed,
and the lock would somehow be renewed by this.
It wasn’t much to go on, but time was running
out.
The Foundation’s Department of Occult Containment
quickly sprang into action, assembling the
materials and placing them in the correct
formation.
While it was not safe to descend that deep
underwater to perform the ritual manually,
technology could fill the role.
A fleet of remotely operated submersibles
equipped with carving material would perform
the ritual without any human hands needed.
The submersibles descended down into the deep,
darkness of the lake and began the ritual,
but midway through, disaster struck.
One of the red bursts occurred midway through
the ritual, causing radiation damage to the
vehicles.
Runes that had been carved in the past were
also damaged, and the ritual was interrupted.
While it seemed like it might have been enough
to activate the site, it wasn’t perfect,
and when the ritual was complete one of the
three cadavers and half of the angel heart
were still present at the site.
Had it been enough to satisfy the ritual and
re-seal the lock?
There was nothing to do but wait and see.
They wouldn’t have to wait long for their
answer, as the mysterious voice once again
took over the televisions in the area.
This time, its message was less friendly - “The
sacrifice did not reach the ten maws.
Brace”.
The Child, apparently, was not satisfied and
the lock was not sealed.
Everyone feared it was too late to prevent
what was coming, and panic was starting to
spread among the ranks.
One day, several personnel stationed at the
Qinghai Lake site broke protocol and fled.
None of them were ever found but one fugitive
staff member, an Agent Zenovia Marinos, left
behind a note though.
It read:
“Do we think we can actually stop this?
No civilization before us wanted to fight
the Child.
None of them…
The sacrifices won't work anymore — it refuses
to consume them.
They aren't enough to satiate it.
Once that seal breaks we'll have a world of
molten darkness and the Child will be all
that's left, eating.
Drinking…
You're fools for staying.”
Agent Marinos was apparently so scared, that
she had fled through a
portal to an extradimensional
space in order to escape.
There would be no point in trying to track
her even if she was still alive.
But in our own dimension, time was running
out.
Foundation seismologists were brought to the
site and stationed outside, and began monitoring
the high-energy pulses coming from behind
the lock.
The energy was reportedly strong enough to
alter dimensions, and the pulsing red light
now covered the entire sealing site, growing
stronger and stronger as the totems started
degrading at an alarming rate.
The Foundation stood on guard for whatever
was about to emerge - but no one knew if they
had any chance against whatever it was.
On August 18th, the totems fully disintegrated.
Some of the Foundation’s best military forces
gathered on the shores of the lake and waited.
Ten minutes later, something massive emerged
phased out of the lock and onto the seabed.
And didn’t move.
The assembled Foundation forces were confused,
and continued to observe the creature and
after no activity was seen after three hours,
the authorization was given for submersibles
and a small exploratory team to proceed down
to the sea bed for an up-close investigation.
There, down on the floor of the lake, was
the Child.
It was as terrifying as described, with countless
mouths and arms, and huge in size, over 40
meters long.
The signs of previous rituals were everywhere,
with angel hearts and human corpses littered
around - some in the creature’s mouth.
But none of them had been eaten.
The ritual had apparently been performed many
times, but to no actual purpose.
The massive being was scanned many times,
but no signs of psychic energy, radiation,
or other life signs were detected.
The Child was dead.
And it had apparently been so for a very,
very long time.
Once the area had been cleared, teams were
brought in to investigate the body in person
and perform an autopsy on-site.
No explanation of what exactly this creature
had been or what its origins were has ever
been discovered, but they did get answers
for when it died.
The time of death was roughly nine thousand
years ago, not long after its initial sealing.
The cause of death was discovered too.
The Child, the destroyer of worlds and scourge
of countless civilizations, had died from
malnutrition.
Whatever this thing had been, it had been
sealed away and had died from hunger not long
after.
One civilization after another had continued
to perform the rituals to keep it sealed,
never aware that it was no longer a threat.
With this new discovery, SCP-4290 was reclassified
as Neutralized, but The Child taught us all
a valuable lesson about being prepared for
potential world ending scenarios, and the
Foundation continues to stand on alert for
any more entities from the distant past that
may pose a threat today.
Because who knows what else is sealed away
at the bottom of a lake, abandoned mine, or
in the ocean’s deepest trenches.
There might just be another existential threat
to humanity that’s just waiting for its
chance to emerge, and help us all if it remembered
to pack a lunch.
A pickaxe shatters the rocky wall of a mineshaft,
hundreds of feet below the earth.
It’s 1871, in a plane that will later be
known as Columbia County, Pennsylvania.
Men perform back-breaking labor, their hands
and faces blackened with dirt, all working
in pursuit of that immensely valuable rock
- coal.
It’s the fuel for the booming industrial
revolution, and much like how dragons were
said to guard gold, this more modern treasure
pointed to an even more terrifying monster.
A monster that the SCP Foundation would someday
come to know as SCP - 1179.
But these unfortunate and underpaid miners
had no idea what they were about to discover.
One of the men working there that day, Rob
O’Dwyer, was hammering away at the wall
in front of him when he heard something strange.
Was that an echo behind the rocks?
This could mean only one thing.
The rocks in front of them were hollow.
There had to be some kind of space hiding
behind them.
O’Dwyer struck again and again at the rocks
in front of him, until the barrier finally
tumbled away.
He and the other miners suddenly felt a gust
of cool, ancient air from the vast and darkened
cavern in front of them sweep through the
mine.
They felt like they were standing on the edge
of something truly otherworldly.
As they lifted their safety lamps high and
crept carefully into the dark, it dawned on
them that they were likely the first human
beings to ever set foot here.
But that didn't mean something non human hadn’t
gotten there first.
O’Dwyer’s lamp soon found something in
the dark.
A huge figure, curled into a crouching position,
hiding its face.
It was made from stone, like an enormous yet
incredibly detailed statue of something almost
human but not quite.
The petrified thing had two great horns on
either side of its head, twisting into spirals
like that of a huge ram.
Word of the giant, frozen monster hidden in
the bottom of the mine soon made its way back
to the Foreman, and then back to the mine’s
owner, one Sean O’Malley.
If it were anyone else, perhaps this news
would have been taken to the press immediately,
and the Foundation would have taken control
of the situation just as quickly.
But Mr. O’Malley was no ordinary mining
magnate - he was a member of the Molly Maguires,
an Irish-American secret society, whose members
were predominantly coal miners in Pennsylvania.
Sean and the other Molly Maguires dubbed this
anomaly the “sleeping stone giant”, and
conspired to keep it a secret between them
- as secret societies have a habit of doing.
Though the Molly Maguires were disbanded less
than a decade later, they were all sworn to
secrecy on the giant’s resting place.
Until, of course, a descendant of Sean O’Malley
- his grandson, Iain O’Malley - was chosen
as a prospective agent of the SCP Foundation.
The Foundation doesn’t just let anyone join
their ranks; they perform an extensive background
check on all prospective agents, both to find
out that they’re capable of rising to the
challenges of the job, and also to detect
any affiliation to enemy Groups of Interest.
It was during this background
check that O’Malley’s
subterranean family secret was discovered,
and the land above the old mine shaft was
bought up by a front company owned by the
Foundation.
The sleeping stone giant was finally in capable
hands, and in keeping with standard procedure,
a research site was built above the giant
to gather data and keep an eye on things.
At the time, the anomaly was considered extremely
low-risk.
Its containment file read: “SCP-1179 is
apparently dormant, encased in the bedrock
under Research Site.
Apart from simple monitoring and standard
research safety protocols,
no additional containment
is deemed necessary at this time.”
But of course, those simple containment procedures
would soon need updating.
In 1962, the town of Centralia, Pennsylvania,
had a trash problem.
There were eight illegal trash dumping sites
across the town, and to combat this issue,
the town council opened up a huge landfill
in an abandoned mineshaft.
You’d think this would be enough for the
moderately sized town, but humans have a tendency
to produce a lot of trash, and they soon filled
up the new landfill too.
In order to address the issue, the town decided
to do a controlled burn of some of the garbage.
It should have been simple enough, but those
who lit this garbage fire didn’t follow
proper safety procedures,
and ended up accidentally
igniting a seam of anthracite coal.
This was like lighting the fuse to the world’s
largest stick of dynamite and fire soon coursed
through the long abandoned mine tunnels.
When the fireball finally reached the sleeping
stone giant in his dark pit, the beast woke
up.
In that instant, an otherwise uneventful day
quickly became a brutal bloodbath.
Researchers walking through the base felt
a monstrous rumbling beneath them.
Heat sensors were burning up and seismic readings
were off the scale.
Something was climbing up towards them.
Suddenly, an impossibly large sword speared
its way out of the floor, killing everyone
around it with an immense blast of heat.
The newly-awakened monster went on an underground
rampage, almost completely destroying the
research base and killing nearly everyone
inside, before retreating into the honeycomb
of coal mines and caverns in the area, igniting
even more anthracite coal fires.
The Foundation needed to step in before things
really got out of control.
At present, the Foundation couldn’t properly
administer standard area construction protocols
for Keter-Class SCPs, so they instead designated
the mines, caverns, and surrounding countryside
as Area-179, and dispatched Mobile Task Forces
to try and contain the beast rampaging in
the Centralia mines.
But much like the fire that started this whole
mess, the beast proved much harder to control
than initially imagined.
All five of the expeditionary teams sent to
apprehend the monster failed, and many team
members were slaughtered in the process.
From the terrified accounts of the survivors,
we have a vague idea of the nature of the
beast below.
No pictures of the creature exist and exact
descriptions on the beast can vary.
Whether this is because the beast frequently
shapeshifts or because it has some kind of
cognitohazardous effects on those who view
it is unclear.
The most frequently reported characteristics
of the creature are its immense height and
the extreme heat that its body exudes.
Many report that the creature’s body seems
to be formed of a mix of hardening lava, pure
fire, and burning smoke.
The beast measures over 30 meters from head
to toe, with shoulders over 8 meters wide.
It’s commonly said to have two huge, ram-like
horns, and a weathered, bearded face.
The beast has been compared by some to the
Norse mythological figure Surtr, the giant
guarding the frontier of the Norse fire realm
of Múspell.
However, the actual age of the creature seems
to predate these legends by a considerable
margin.
Dating of the stratum encasing SCP-1179 indicates
it dates to the Mississippian subperiod of
the Carboniferous period, approximately 359.2
to 318.1 million years ago.
This age is consistent with the geological
age of this region, so it may have literally
come with the territory.
Less common descriptions of the beast claim
that it has huge wings, eyes made of hellfire,
and fangs as long as a man’s arm.
Some say the beast has neither horns nor fangs,
and its face is encircled by flames which
reach down into a long beard of fire.
And like a certain creature known as the Balrog
that Lord of the Rings fans will be very familiar
with, this beast comes with weapons.
In one hand, the beast wields a giant, burning
sword, around five meters in length.
In the other, it wields a huge, multi-tailed
whip made out of fire.
It’s incredibly proficient with these weapons,
too, and has a serious strategic advantage
in its underground environment.
Foundation researchers have determined that
some of the wounds the beast gained from its
first confrontation haven’t fully healed,
implying that the beast could - in theory
- be destroyed with enough firepower.
However, given that the beast has killed almost
everyone who faced it, and its mere presence
can start almost uncontrollable fires, direct
engagement would only be used as a last resort.
Even the creature’s breath can be extremely
dangerous.
Chemical analysis of air samples taken from
SCP-1179’s breath have shown exceptionally
high concentrations of carbon monoxide and
sulfur dioxide.
The very presence of this creature creates
a real and active danger to everyone around
it.
And the beast’s presence was beginning to
have seriously negative effects on the people
up above.
By the 1970s, the Foundation had given up
on sending Mobile Task Forces into the caverns,
and instead began to focus on depopulating
the town of Centralia to
prevent further fatalities
from the presence of SCP - 1179.
The subterranean activities of the creature
were causing collapses in some areas, and
noxious fumes were beginning to rise up from
cracks in the ground.
As the constantly raging fires burned beneath
the earth, they were causing everything above
to slowly melt or bake.
A Foundation geologist determined that the
fires created by the beast would likely remain
active for 250 years, and any attempts to
put out the fires or contain the beast would
ultimately be futile.
This led to the formation of Project Tartarus,
a concerted effort to cover up SCP - 1179
and fully evacuate the citizens of Centralia.
They pushed the narrative that the mine fires,
while deadly, were merely the\ result of the
failed garbage burning plan, and little by
little, the people of Centralia began to move
away.
By 1984, the United States Government finally
caved to secret lobbying from the Foundation,
and allocated funds in excess of $42 million
to relocate the remaining civilian residents
from the area.
Any legal complaints from Centralia residents
were quietly crushed by the Foundation, and
efforts to remove pretty much all residents
from the area were successful.
This allowed the Foundation to finally cast
a wider net and administer Keter-Class containment
protocols around the two-kilometer underground
zone where SCP - 1179 resides.
The Foundation has continued studies on the
beast from below in the decades since, with
some scientists even suggesting it could be
used to produce geothermal energy, but whether
or not that would actually be feasible remains
unknown.
For now SCP-1179 seems content to stay within
its zone, and hopefully it stays that way.
But as we’re forced to dig deeper and deeper
for the remaining precious metals here on
earth, there’s no telling what new dangers
we might find lurking far below the ground.
It was 1948, in Villa Blanca, Guatemala.
As night fell, two young boys - Carlos and
Miguel - played a game of soccer in the street.
It was a quiet town full of humble, hard-working
people, and they were about to come face to
face with a monster.
Typically, when something like this happened,
you’d know exactly who to call: The SCP
Foundation.
Problem is, while these days we can generally
depend on the hard-working agents and researchers
of the Foundation to save us from any anomalous,
supernatural threats with
their tactics, expertise,
and equipment, it wasn’t always this way.
There was a time before the SCP Foundation
became the titan of anomaly-combatting prowess
it is today, and it’s that time that we’re
focusing on today.
It all comes back to a strange and violent
creature wandering the darkened streets of
Guatemala.
Or, as Dr. Charles Odgen Gears proposed we
call it, SCP-001 - The Prototype.
SCP-001 is a topic we’ve covered in a number
of videos, but even then, we can never quite
capture the full scope of this wily designation.
“What is SCP-001?” is probably one of
the most loaded questions you can possibly
ask as a member of the SCP Foundation, and
it may be your last, as the majority of the
files under the SCP-001 umbrella are highly
classified for pretty much everyone under
Level 5 clearance.
001 covers a large number of potentially anomalous
items, entities, and concepts, from the dreaded
Scarlet King, to the awe-inspiring Gate Guardian,
to the very SCP Foundation itself, through
the eyes of the charmingly incompetent Unusual
Incidents Unit of the FBI.
Perhaps they’re all real, perhaps only one
of them is, and the rest are in there as a
smokescreen.
Perhaps they’re all fake, red herrings laid
down to hide the trail to something even more
secretive and fantastic.
All we know is that 001s seem to be gathered
around a collection of loose themes - The
beginnings of the Foundation, events or entities
that could end the Foundation or even the
world, and key formative moments in the
Foundation’s
history.
Dr. Gears’ proposal for SCP-001 lies firmly
in the latter camp.
And if you keep watching and listening closely,
you’ll see exactly why.
Back to Carlos and Miguel,
the pair of eleven-year-olds
playing soccer on the quiet back streets of
Villa Blanca.
They were kicking the ball back and forth
when they heard a strange screeching noise
in the distance.
At first, they thought it was some kind of
injured bird, squawking desperately for help.
Being good kids, they didn’t waste a second
running into the action, heading further into
the outskirts of town.
However, the creature they encountered on
that rural road was certainly no bird.
When they first saw it, hunched over a few
meters in front of them, they thought it must
have been a horribly injured man.
He was deathly thin, with gray-brown skin
that looked either bruised or burned.
It was twitching and weeping, its chest heaving
in heavy, labored pants.
Its limbs were jerking wildly, as though the
creature was being electrocuted.
“Hey mister, are you okay?”
Carlos called out in Spanish.
In that moment, what they had wrongly thought
was a man just froze up, finally registering
their presence.
Immediately, the two boys knew something was
wrong, as the creature slowly rose to its
full height: Well over six feet, towering
over the two of them, even at a distance.
They noticed something was wrong with its
limbs: They were too long, well out of proportion
with its human-sized torso.
It didn’t have hands and feet - At least,
not in the way that humans do.
Instead, its slender ankles terminated in
long, black spikes, and its wrists each split
off into three equally black claws.
But worst of all was its face, if you could
even call what that monster had a face.
Its head was split in the middle by a huge
mouth.
At first, its gnarly lips were pursed, but
they soon slid open with a low, rumbling roar.
The boys could feel their knees shaking as
they saw the monster’s mouthful of long,
rotten fangs.
Something started sliding up the dark passage
of the monster’s throat: A translucent,
milky-blue sphere.
Was that thing an eye?
It made the two boys feel sick to even look
at it.
That’s when the “eye” started to glow,
and the space around the monster began to
shimmer slightly, like some kind of terrible
sorcery.
As the two boys felt a strange force pulling
at them, trying to tug them into the creature’s
embrace, they were suddenly jogged from their
frightened paralysis and decided to finally
make a run for it.
There was no doubt about what had just happened:
They’d encountered a demon in the flesh,
intent on taking their souls straight to hell.
When the two of them told their parents, they
were met at first with disbelief.
Two young boys saw something that frightened
them in the dark - perhaps an animal, if anything
at all - and they’d let their imaginations
run wild.
It was typical of children.
However, things didn’t seem quite so simple
when more sightings started popping up.
People all across the town of Villa Blanca
started seeing this monster, all with matching
descriptions: A huge, emaciated beast with
a mouth for a face, its glowing blue eye nested
inside.
The natural excuses circulated at first: Perhaps
the creature was a local prankster in a costume?
This would be comforting to believe, but how
many pranksters in costumes can completely
disappear before your very eyes.
The monster’s eye would glow, and just like
that, it would simply vanish.
As fear and paranoia began spreading through
the town, people suggested that perhaps it
was a case of mass hysteria - Fear and panic
taking over rationality.
But by this point, things had gotten worse:
Carlos and Miguel, the two boys who’d first
discovered the demon on the back road, had
become sick.
They were experiencing severe nausea, vomiting,
headaches, and diarrhea.
Their bodies weakened.
Lesions began developing on their skin.
As their conditions deteriorated, and it seemed
as though nobody was capable of helping them,
a rumor spread that the monster was somehow
inducing this sickness.
The town doctor didn’t have the expertise
to diagnose it, but the boys were suffering
from acute radiation sickness.
And they wouldn’t be the only ones.
Many of the people who’d reported sightings
and close encounters with the monster started
coming down with severe radiation sickness.
To the townspeople, it just seemed to be a
demon spreading some invisible plague among
them.
But the horrors wouldn’t stop there.
It seemed that this demon also liked to take
a more direct approach to harming the townsfolk,
because not long after the sickness broke
out, people started disappearing.
There were never any bodies.
The most that would ever be found were tattered
items of clothing left at the site of the
disappearances, or blood smeared across the
walls or ground.
Before they knew it, seven of their people
were gone.
It seemed that, for all intents and purposes,
God had abandoned them.
They were playthings of the demon now.
Thankfully for the townsfolk who weren’t
yet irradiated or vanished, an organization
was forming.
One that might be their only chance at salvation.
Someday in the future, it would become known
as The SCP Foundation, but it had a lot to
learn before it got there.
You see, the reason that this iteration of
SCP-001 is known as The Prototype is that
- if Dr. Gears is to be believed - it may
be the first anomalous entity that they ever
truly faced.
So naturally, getting the creature captured
and contained didn’t go quite as smoothly
as most of their modern jobs, despite the
comparative simplicity of this old threat.
General Machoi, an ex-military operator that
became part of what we’ll once again call
The Precursors to the Foundation, led a research
and recovery team into Villa Blanca to hunt
down and retrieve the beast that’d been
causing all this misery and death among the
townsfolk.
However, this proved to be easier said than
done.
While its bestial appearance might fool people
into thinking the monster was just a mindless
animal, later writings on the creature would
describe it as both incredibly cunning and
terrifyingly fast.
When a group of armed personnel first tried
to engage the creature directly, they had
no idea that they were walking right into
the middle of a bloodbath.
They believed they had it surrounded on another
rural back road, advancing with assault rifles,
when the creature flipped out and started
killing them.
The Prototype proved to have frightening offensive
capabilities.
Its three dark claws easily carved through
the armor of the soldiers trying desperately
to contain it.
The creature moved so fast that none of them
could reliably draw a bead on it, and if any
of them could, it was holding their severed
head before they had a chance to squeeze the
trigger.
But death by the creature’s claws was one
of the more pleasant ways it could kill its
victims.
At one point during an engagement with Precursor
troops, it opened its mouth and unveiled its
glowing, blue eye.
At this point, one of the soldiers screamed,
and suddenly seemed to be sucked inside of
himself, completely disappearing.
The Prototype’s blue eye glowed again, and
it once again just teleported away from the
scene.
A number of the soldiers who survived this
altercation later needed to be treated for
acute radiation sickness.
Researchers eventually managed to figure out
what was actually happening with the creature:
It had the ability to manifest microsingularities
- tiny black holes that it used to both teleport
from place to place, and defend itself from
attacks when necessary.
These singularities wouldn’t stick around
for long, a few seconds at most, but they
had the terrifying side effect of putting
out massive amounts of radiation.
This is why it was making so much of the town
and the recovery team sick via mere proximity.
Thankfully, in finding out the creature’s
strength, they also managed to find out its
weaknesses.
Its powers were dampened by high humidity,
bright lights, and especially intense strobing
lights.
It was through the use of these lights that
the creature was finally captured and brought
into ADRX-19 - a complex that would later
become Site-19 - for containment.
There, its containment procedures were devised
by one of the burgeoning organization’s
top minds: Dr. Hermann Keter.
However, Dr. Keter would sadly never actually
live to see the duration of the Prototype’s
containment at ADRX-19 - He was tragically
killed by the monster, though his name would
live on as the designation for anomalies that
were particularly difficult to contain.
It was thanks to him that his coworkers realized
lead-lined walls, a reinforced steel door,
a 100% humidity environment, and the frequent
application of high-intensity strobe lights
were the best way to keep the Prototype locked
up for good.
To this day, this iteration of SCP-001 is
a fascinating reminder that the SCP Foundation
wasn’t always the juggernaut it is today.
There was once a time when they had as little
idea of what they were doing as the rest of
us.
There’s no better representation of this
than the file itself: It was an era before
object classes and conventional designation
numbers.
The file is written in a sketchy, disorganized
manner, and arranged into “Item designation
number”, “Warning”, “Description of
item”, “Detail of current containment”,
“Report”, and “addendum.”
As with any experience in life, it’s always
worth asking: What can we learn from the SCP
Foundation’s experience with its possible
first anomaly, a monster that seems almost
nostalgically quaint by today’s standards?
Perhaps the greatest message is that everything
is a work in progress.
It was only by determination and persistence
that the Foundation could go from an organization
challenged by a monster like The Prototype
to going toe to toe with real heavy hitters
like the Scarlet King.
How very inspirational.
We have always been afraid of the dark.
Ancient ancestors of mankind built fires to
chase the shadows away, to keep the thick,
black mystery of night from encroaching on
their fragile little homes with all of the
teeth and claws it hid within its depths.
From the time we were small children, we knew
to be nervous when the lights went out.
We beg our parents to leave the hall light
on or plug in a nightlight, praying that a
tiny sliver of illumination will protect us
from the monsters we just know are salivating
beneath the bed, scratching against the closet
door, waiting for us to close our eyes.
We pull the blankets tight over our heads,
heating the air with our panicked breaths
and reminding ourselves that the shadow in
the corner of the room was just a rocking
chair or a coat rack.
We pretend it’s the truth.
But there’s a reason we fear the darkness
as much as we do.
It’s inherent.
It’s a memory passed down from generation
to generation ever since we first learned
how to scream.
As adults, we try to tell ourselves we’ve
outgrown those childish fears and night terrors.
We know better now.
But you still run up the darkened staircase
as if something’s chasing you and your heart
jumps into your throat when you hear a sound
after midnight.
Call it el cucuy, the kludde, the boogeyman,
or a thousand other names; we all know there
is something lurking in the dark.
And it knows us too.
D-Class 080-1 was pulled from his cell one
afternoon and brought to a containment chamber.
He knew the drill by now.
They would send him in and he would encounter
something bizarre, horrible, and potentially
deadly.
Maybe he would emerge traumatized, maybe he
would lose a limb, or maybe he would never
come back out at all.
A security guard opened the door and instructed
him to enter.
It wasn’t an ideal situation, but he really
didn’t have much of a choice.
And so, he walked inside.
Dr. Smith called to him from outside the room,
asking him what he could see inside.
It was pitch black, and he couldn’t see
a thing, and he told the doctor as much.
But then…the hairs on the back of his neck
prickled.
A chill rippled down his spine.
He had the distinct feeling that something
was looking right at him.
Watching.
Waiting.
“Did you just let something in here?”
He asked.
“It feels like something’s watching me.”
“No, D-080-1.”
Dr. Smith responded.
“We did not let anything into the room.”
The man’s hands were shaking, and he could
feel sweat beading on his forehead.
That couldn’t be true.
He wasn’t alone in here.
There, in the corner!
There was a black mass, large and somehow
even darker than the rest of the room.
He could feel its eyes on his, boring into
him.
His heart thudded in his chest and he felt
like he might be sick.
He tried to take a step back but his ankle
folded under him and he collapsed to the floor.
“What do you see?”
Dr. Smith asked.
The man struggled to find the words.
“This giant blackness, like someone just
standing in the corner.
Oh God, it’s looking right at me!
Let me out!”
He climbed to his feet and felt his way along
the wall until he reached the door, and began
to pound against it with his fists.
The Doctor refused to let him out until he
described the being’s appearance.
“It looks like a figure, hunched in the
corner.”
“Is it a human?”
Dr. Smith asked.
Though he knew it was too dark for the doctor
to see, he shook his head.
“It’s too big to be a human.
It’s still looking at me, Doc, still staring.”
Though he should have had adrenaline pumping
through his body, he felt suddenly sleepy,
almost unable to keep his eyes open.
“Move closer to it.”
Dr. Smith ordered.
The D-class obeyed, though he swayed on his
feet as he walked.
“Its eyes look like vapor, just staring
at me.
Like it wants me to do someth-“
At this point, he fell to the ground again,
suddenly silent.
Dr. Smith called out to him again and again,
but the man did not respond.
When the research team opened the containment
chamber several minutes later, D-080-1 was
gone.
He was lost to the thing that waits for us
in the dark.
He was lost to SCP-080.
This was the first in a series of tests that
a Foundation research team, headed by Dr.
Smith, performed in order to better understand
this shadowy figure and determine whether
or not it has a physical body of any kind.
When the results were
determined to be unsatisfactory,
another experiment was conducted.
A woman referred to as D-080-2 was selected
and sent into the room.
This time, they would attempt to have the
D-class touch the entity.
Upon entering the chamber, D-080-2 remarked
on how dark it was, and how difficult it was
to see anything inside.
After several minutes, however, she noticed
something standing in the room.
When prompted, the only descriptor she could
give was that the entity had two eyes.
Dr. Smith asked her to approach the entity
and report any changes.
As she got closer, she became increasingly
drowsy and exhausted.
When she reached out to touch SCP-080, she
went quiet and did not respond to any additional
questions.
She was found asleep in the corner of the
containment room, and was immediately examined
by medical staff.
No adverse physical effects were found, and
an interview was conducted to determine if
there was any residual psychological impact.
In her interview, D-080-2 was noticeably distant,
her expression and tone of voice both described
as “spaced out.”
When asked about her encounter with the entity,
she became increasingly upset and began to
hyperventilate.
She screamed: “It just stared and stared,
not moving but I felt something!
I was on the floor and they were all over
me.
They’re here!
No, they’re trying to take me away, back
to that thing.
I won’t go back!
You can’t make me go back in there!”
At this point, she lunged across the table
and attempted to attack Dr. Smith.
She was removed from the interview room and
later terminated.
A third experiment was conducted, using a
man referred to as D-080-3.
In order to counteract the entity’s tranquilizing
effects, he was given a powerful amphetamine
at a dose that would keep a person under ordinary
circumstances awake for at least 36 hours.
When he entered the room, like all the others,
D-080-3 saw a shadowy figure standing in the
middle of the room.
He was told to stand still and watch the figure,
and report anything unusual that he might
notice.
After ten minutes, the subject became frightened
and demanded to be let out of the room.
He pounded on the door, and attempted to wedge
it open.
When he failed to open the door, he lunged
at SCP-080 and attempted to hit it with his
fists.
He promptly slumped to the floor and went
silent.
His dead body was found in the room after
the experiment, and an autopsy determined
the cause of death to be a severe heart attack.
The researchers who entered to retrieve the
body felt unsettled as they did so, reporting
a feeling that SCP-080 was looking directly
at them the entire time.
Following the conclusion of these experiments,
the research team was able to draw several
conclusions about SCP-080.
It causes debilitating drowsiness in anyone
who enters its containment chamber.
After thirty minutes of exposure, anyone who
is observing the entity will involuntarily
fall into REM sleep.
If there is any light in the room brighter
than a standard children’s night light,
the entity will disappear.
This should be treated as a containment breach
if and when it occurs.
After conducting their experiments, Dr. Smith
and his research team began to experience
highly upsetting dreams.
While many of the staff
began requesting appointments
with the medical team, Dr. Smith refused to
discuss the nature of his dreams with any
on-site psychologists, insisting that he wasn’t
going to let some silly nightmares get the
better of him.
As the weeks wore on, however, he became
increasingly
withdrawn.
His colleagues noted dark circles under his
eyes, and noticed his near-constant consumption
of coffee that far surpassed anything they
had seen from him before.
He seemed as if he was terrified of falling
asleep.
One day, the exhaustion caught up to him and
he fell asleep at his desk.
Everyone in the building heard his screams,
and when a security guard eventually shook
him awake, his throat was so raw from crying
out in terror that he was coughing up globs
of blood.
Dr. Smith begged to be given an amnestic,
to help him forget what he had dreamed about,
forget all of his dreams, but the request
was denied.
He was placed on an indefinite leave of absence
and sent home.
Two days later, the research team was given
a somber report: Dr. Smith had leapt off a
bridge.
Following Dr. Smith’s tragic demise, the
rest of his staff were given notebooks and
encouraged to keep dream journals during the
course of their research in order to track
the psychological impact of studying SCP-080.
Additionally, they were required to turn these
journals in to the site psychologists for
review, particularly if the dreams became
especially disturbing or violent.
The following are excerpts from some of these
dream journals.
Research Assistant Megan Vaughn:
“Last night I dreamt I was lying in my bed.
Not my bed now, in my apartment, but my childhood
bed with the baby pink sheets and the quilt
my grandmother made.
It felt so real, every detail.
My dollhouse in the corner, my big teddy bear,
my tea set, and my closet.
I was lying on my side, with my head facing
my closet.
I used to be so scared of that closet.
Every night I would sob until my dad checked
it for monsters.
I couldn’t go to sleep until he did.
But in my dream, I knew he hadn’t checked.
And I just knew there was something in there
waiting for me to close my eyes.
So I didn’t, I just stared at that closet
door and I waited for it to open.
I started to hear this scraping noise, like
dragging something sharp across a wooden surface.
Over and over again.
But the door didn’t budge, no matter how
long I stared at it.
All the while the noise just kept going.
Scrape.
And the sound of soft, raspy breathing.
But the closet stayed shut.
Eventually, I rolled onto my back, and there
it was.
On my ceiling, hanging over
me with its upside-down
head and round, open mouth, an old woman with
long stringy hair and fingernails as long
as my arms.
She was scratching on the ceiling, and waiting
for me to look.
I couldn’t move, I could just stare up at
her as she took two of
those long, long fingernails
and slowly inched them toward my eyes…and
then I woke up.
I’m scared if I go back to sleep, she’ll
pick up right where she left off.”
Dr. Owen Kohli:
“I’m swimming in my family’s pond, and
it’s a beautiful sunny day outside.
I can feel the sun’s heat on my skin, and
the crisp cold water cooling it every time
I dip under the surface.
I decide to swim down toward the bottom and
dive for rocks, and when I come back up, suddenly
it’s dark.
It’s the middle of the night, and the water
doesn’t look so clear anymore.
I can’t see the bottom.
I can’t see anything around me at all.
And I feel something slither against my leg.
I kick it away, but I just feel something
else on my other side.
Slimy and quick.
I can’t see it, but I can feel that it's
much bigger than me.
So I start swimming toward the edge, trying
to get out before something worse happens.
Then I feel this sharp pain, like a hundred
needles stabbing into my back.
It hurts so bad I see red, but I keep swimming.
I reached the edge and I try to pull myself
out but I can’t, there’s something on
me and it’s so heavy I can’t get out.
I look over my shoulder and I can now make
it out: it’s the biggest leech I’ve ever
seen, and it’s latched on to me.
I can see it pulsating, swallowing.
It’s draining me.
And I feel so weak all of a sudden, dizzy,
and I look down at my hands and they’re
shriveling up right there, my fingers pruning
as I feel the blood being pulled out of me.
My vision blurs and my head tips back and
I’m sinking down into the water as the leech
keeps sucking.
It pulls down into the muck at the bottom,
and everything goes dark.”
Researcher Kathy Levine:
“Okay, in my dream I was in my old house,
back when I lived out in the woods.
No cell reception and no neighbors.
I was in the shower, washing my hair I think?
It’s hard to remember the details.
I don’t remember the details of dreams very
well, but I’ll do my best.
This part I do remember: I heard this sound,
like footsteps coming from the floor above
me, that quiet thudding sound coming down
through the ceiling.
I turned off the water to listen better, and
there it was again.
Definitely footsteps.
Someone was in my house.
I threw on my clothes and slowly snuck out
of the bathroom, and made my way to the front
door.
I don’t know why, I just knew I needed to
get out of there.
Just when I opened it, I heard the footsteps
behind me and I turned around, and there was
this man there.
Huge, like seven feet tall, massive tangled
beard, wild eyes, and holding an axe.
We stared at each other for a long time, and
he just smiled.
Like he was so sure he was going to kill me,
and have a lovely time doing it.
I ran out of the house and into the woods,
and I could hear him coming after me.
Branches hit me in the face and cut up my
arms as I ran, and I just knew I had to get
away.
But then I started to get that feeling you
get when you run in dreams, like your legs
don’t work.
Like you’re pushing through water.
I was running as fast as I could, but I wasn’t
going forward at all.
And then I felt a hand grabbing my hair, yanking
my head back, and the blade of the axe slicing
across my cheek.
He whispered in my ear, and his breath smelled
like rotting flesh.
And I’ll never forget this next part, he
said “We’re not done playing yet.
I’m going to take you apart in tiny pieces,
and save your head for last.”
Dr. Robert Gray:
“I was sitting on the couch, next to my
wife.
We were watching television.
I turned to ask her a question, and she was
staring at me with these dilated pupils, so
big her eyes looked all black.
Then she opened her mouth, to speak to me,
I thought.
But it got wider and wider, and it had no
teeth, just this expanding tunnel of pink
flesh that started to suck me inside until
my head disappeared into her mouth and I began
to suffocate.
I haven’t been able to look my wife in the
eye all day today.”
Other dream journals were less detailed.
Research Assistant Matt Guerrero simply wrote
“My dog ate me,” while Senior Researcher
Barbara Bradley wrote: “I was stuck inside
my fish tank, and my fish were feeding me
human flakes.”
No matter how frightening or absurd the dreams
detailed were, all the
staff reporting experiencing
feelings of intense stress and panic while
having them, and after waking up.
SCP-080 is contained in a 4m x 4m room with
a small antechamber on the south wall, providing
researchers with access to the space.
On the other side of the north wall, there
is an observation room where researchers can
view the containment room through a window.
The window is outfitted with thin blackout
curtains, which release when the observation
room door has fully closed.
No one may attempt to remove SCP-080 from
its containment at any time,
under any circumstances.
No light sources may be brought into the room,
and no more than one seven watt incandescent
lightbulb may be lit inside.
Additionally, no objects may be brought into
the room that can be used to hide SCP-080
in any way.
Anyone who breaks these rules will be swiftly
and strictly disciplined, and may be subject
to termination.
Following Incident 080-1, the containment
measures have been reevaluated and additional
measures have been proposed.
During this incident, two senior researchers
entered the observation room and released
the blackout curtains.
Certain that this was a safe way to observe
SCP-080 without being influenced by its adverse
effects, the two remained in the room for
forty minutes.
At this point, the two fell asleep.
It is unknown what exactly happened after
this.
However, after this incident, all staff suffering
from anomalous nightmares reported having
their first restful night of sleep since the
research had begun.
It was as if the entity’s appetite had been
temporarily sated, and it had released the
rest of the team from its influence.
In light of Incident 080-1, a member of the
research team suggested that a D Class be
left in SCP-080’s room once a month in order
to feed it, and protect the rest of the team
from psychological harm.
After some debate, and opposition from the
ethics committee, this proposal was approved
by the O5 Council.
Now, the entity is kept on a regular feeding
schedule, and the staff’s dream journals
have been relatively uneventful ever since.
It turns out that sometimes the price for
a good night’s sleep is just a little bit
of human sacrifice.
Who doesn’t love a walk through a dark forest? The
sight of branches set against the low moonlight
looking like all manner of dark and twisted claws
reaching out of the night to grab at you. Every
step brings with it the snap of a broken twig
that practically echoes around you. Whenever a
breeze rustles the leaves on the trees, you feel
like something might just be following you, moving
through the forest towards you. It’s easy to get
lost in a forest at night, after all, that’s why
the children’s song warns us that “if you go down
to the woods today, you’d better not go alone.”
The image of a forest in the darkness has inspired
fear for generations, from fireside folktales
telling of wolves and monsters lurking among
the trees, to modern horror games about a tall,
faceless man in a suit stalking you through the
woods. And then, of course, there’s SCP-060,
otherwise known as the Infernal Occult Skeleton.
Now, despite its name, SCP-060 is, in actual fact,
a forest. Or at least, it’s a forest to begin
with. A picturesque grove of seventeen tall,
white oak trees, spread out across eight acres
of land in rural northeast Minnesota. It almost
looks like something out of a tourist brochure,
a beautiful stretch of forest sitting under clear
skies, well, during the daytime anyway.
If you ever find yourself hiking through
a corner of Minnesotan forest that isn’t in
any of the guidebooks, then tread carefully.
You might just stumble upon the demolished ruins
of a house that used to stand among the trees,
out in seclusion. And a word of advice to you if
you happen across this place, do not, under any
circumstances, stop walking for a smoke break.
Of course, thanks to the good folks at the SCP
Foundation, you’re unlikely to ever just wander
your way into SCP-060. More likely, they’ll
administer you with amnestics – the Foundation’s
patented memory-altering drugs – and send you on
your merry way, totally oblivious to the huge,
hard-to-miss greenhouses containing SCP-060.
Beyond those glass walls, you might have caught
glimpses of Foundation personnel watering the
trees, carefully tending to each SCP-060 specimen.
Maybe you saw them gathering up leaves and pruning
each tree individually, composting every part
of dead plant matter instead of leaving the
white oaks to grow freely. And perhaps you
even noticed that not one member of personnel
was carrying a lighter on their person, nor a
taser, or so much as a small box of matches,
nothing that can start a fire. Or rather,
you would remember seeing all that,
if the amnestics hadn’t already made you forget.
But what’s so special about these trees? Why would
the SCP Foundation go to the extent of housing
a collection of white oaks in greenhouses,
and meticulously oversee their growth? What
is it about these particular specimens that
make personnel so cautious about fire
safety? And why on earth is SCP-060,
a collection of trees, referred to by the
nickname ‘the Infernal Occult Skeleton’?
Well, the answer to all those questions
becomes pretty apparent the moment any
of the SCP-060 oak trees catch fire, and
something comes hurtling out of the forest.
That something is known as SCP-060-Alpha.
Standing at just over two meters tall,
the entity takes the form of an adult human
skeleton. Much more than just a spooky,
scary collection of bones, SCP-060-Alpha is
fully animate, capable of moving of its own
accord without the aid of muscles or a nervous
system. Oh, and it also happens to be on fire.
Move aside Ghost Rider, SCP-060-Alpha is engulfed
from skull to toe bones in bright white flames,
burning at a temperature of approximately
fifteen-hundred degrees Celsius, or almost
three thousand degrees Fahrenheit. For reference,
that’s just shy of the melting point of iron,
and hot enough to grant a human being
a quick, but agonizingly painful death.
Granted after a few seconds of that heat your
nerve endings would be scalded, so maybe you
wouldn’t feel that much pain. But fifteen-hundred
Celsius is enough to burn the moisture right out
of your skin, melt your eyeballs, and generally
fry you to a crisp in a matter of minutes,
if not seconds. Good thing SCP-060-Alpha isn’t
known for being highly aggressive and hostile.
Oh, wait, it is? Ah, not good.
Upon manifestation, the burning
skeleton will attempt to do as much damage as
possible, and usually to whoever is closest.
It can appear at any time, and after as little as
twenty grams worth of one of the SCP-060 trees is
burned. As if being actively hostile and burning
hot enough to reshape metal wasn’t bad enough,
SCP-060-Alpha has also shown itself to be fiercely
intelligent. The entity seems to retain knowledge
whenever it manifests and has gained a
growing familiarity with the layout of the
Foundation site that contains the SCP-060 oaks.
The Infernal Occult Skeleton’s methods of attack
tend to include throwing its entire body at
flammable materials; however, it will avoid
causing any damage to specimens of SCP-060. The
skeletal entity can run at speeds of up to fifty
miles per hour, now that’s almost the same speed
as a gazelle. Just picturing anything traveling
towards you at that speed is horrifying, let
alone something heading straight for you at
gazelle levels of speed while also on fire!
It’s this combination of speed and heat that
means SCP-060-Alpha poses such a threat to anyone
close whenever it appears; if left unchecked,
the entity could easily cause colossal and
widespread forest fires and property damage.
Interestingly, any areas that SCP-060-Alpha
does burn with its flames, will start to
yield saplings of the SCP-060 oaks, around
six weeks after the fire has stopped. The
Foundation doesn’t allow these saplings to grow
to full size, and instead pulls them from the
ground and disposes of them, composting the
saplings to feed the other SCP-060 specimens.
Luckily, the biggest strength of SCP-060-Alpha,
its flames, also happens to be its greatest
weakness. It is possible to fight the fires
of the Infernal Occult Skeleton by dousing
it with water or any other materials capable of
dousing flames, whether it’s sand or foam from
a fire extinguisher. Of course, this is a lot
hotter and harder to put out than any ordinary,
smaller-scale fire, but despite being
a difficult task, it’s not impossible.
About five hundred liters of water should do the
trick if you’ve got a big enough bucket nearby.
After that, SCP-060-Alpha will be weakened,
gradually collapsing and turning into dust.
However, if another part of an SCP-060 tree is
burned and the entity reappears, it is believed
that this will be the same Infernal Occult
Skeleton, rather than a new version of the bone
burning being. So, we have a grove of oak trees
that manifest a flaming skeleton if they are ever
burned. Maybe that’s not the weirdest thing you’d
see in a Minnesotan forest, but wait, there’s
something else. Cast your mind back a few minutes,
and you’ll remember that we mentioned some ruins,
the remains of a demolished house that used to
stand secluded among the SCP-060 white oak trees.
Knowing that the Infernal Occult Skeleton
can appear from the oaks might make it
obvious what happened to this house, but
there’s still a story to be told here.
The house’s owner was a man by the name of
Johnathan Corhill. Now, Johnathan was something
of an odd man, considered a bit of an eccentric to
some. He preferred to spend his time in solitude,
alone with his own thoughts for company, rather
than mingling among the rest of the world. Even
his own family noticed that Mr. Corhill was
drifting away from them, becoming a more bitter,
nihilistic person in his old age, and choosing
isolation over human connection. Now, sure,
loneliness doesn’t hold much appeal
to everyone, but sometimes there are
people who just prefer being alone. That
might be what drew Johnathan Corhill to
his secluded little house in the forests of
Minnesota, somewhere no one would bother him.
For the most part, the rest of the Corhill family
adjusted to their eccentric relative’s behavior.
Johnathan would have rarely accepted
visitors to his house in the forest,
but he still kept in contact with those he’d been
close with. Most notably, he’d regularly share
phone calls with his brother, one Christopher
Corhill. That is... Until something seemed
to change unexpectedly, in the year 1996.
On one of their calls, Johnathan outright
told Christopher to never contact him again,
severing all ties with any remaining family
members and friends in the outside world.
Johnathan cut everyone off, living within
his own bubble where he could immerse himself in
his unusual interests. According to Christopher,
his brother had seemed otherwise normal up until
a certain phone conversation, but Johnathan had
become obsessed with the occult. Specifically,
he had embroiled himself in the history of the
Victorian-era, and certain supernatural practices
that had been undertaken in that time period.
Now whether Christopher honored his brother’s
wish to sever ties is unknown. A mail carrier
would visit Johnathan’s home in the woods not long
after their phone call. Maybe among the envelopes,
this courier was delivering what could have been
a letter from Christopher, or other members of
the Corhill family, begging their estranged
relative to come back to the world. You see,
even people who claim to prefer being on their
own sometimes need human interaction. Talking
to people, being in the presence of friends
and family, are hugely important factors in
maintaining a positive state of mental health.
But what happens when someone rejects that
entirely and instead becomes lost in
their obsessive study of the occult? Well,
the mail carrier was the first to find out.
Arriving at Johnathan Corhill’s woodland house,
the courier found the place looking almost
skeletal, a shell of the building that had
once stood in the forest. According to the locals,
the carrier had been sent to deliver a notice to
Mr Corhill, explaining that his house was
being foreclosed. But it seemed someone,
or something, had beaten them to it. A
fire had spread from the house’s fireplace,
quickly engulfing the entire structure,
presumably with Johnathan still inside.
It wasn’t until later that very same year
that Johnathan Corhill was officially
reported as a missing person case with local
authorities. Any search that was undertaken
in an attempt to find him uncovered
next to no evidence of his whereabouts.
To this day, nobody knows for certain if
Johnathan Corhill is dead or alive, his
whereabouts are unknown. On the surface, it might
be easy to make the assumption that the Infernal
Occult Skeleton reduced the reclusive old man to
nothing more than a cinder. It definitely seems
plausible that Johnathan, collecting firewood to
keep himself warm in his isolation, accidentally
chopped down part of an SCP-060 oak, put it in his
fireplace, and called forth the vengeful flaming
bones. But perhaps we shouldn’t be so certain.
After all, Corhill’s house wasn’t entirely burned
down, despite the entity normally trying to cause
as much damage as possible whenever it appears.
And on top of that, no human remains were found
in the house. And the skeleton of SCP-060-Alpha
had to have come from somewhere, right?
SCP-060 offers a few warnings, and not just
about the dangers of traveling through the forest
alone. The appearance of the flaming skeleton
whenever the SCP-060 white oaks are burned
could serve as a reminder that we need to be
vigilant in protecting the forests of this world.
Trees are one of our few sustainable resources,
but for every one we cut down or that catches
fire, it takes years to regrow a replacement.
And perhaps the third and final warning
of the Infernal Occult Skeleton is simply:
don’t play with matches, especially around
trees. Otherwise, you might get burned.
Imagine if you could predict the future.
Not perfectly, mind you, but with enough accuracy
that brilliant enough minds - say, the best
and brightest of the SCP Foundation - could
plausibly reverse-engineer the main determinative
factors that caused a certain timeline to
form.
Imagine if, through carefully studying these
determinative factors, the Foundation could
carefully shape the future into one that’s
more favorable for the human race than all
the alternatives.
The “Preferred Option”, if you will.
Would this not be advantageous?
Your next question is a very natural one,
given the circumstances: How does one predict
the future in such a manner?
Well, the answer is uncomplicated, but that
doesn’t by any means make it easy: You go
there, spend a few months looking around,
and then come back to report your findings.
That’s right, folks - We’re not talking
psychics and seers here.
Prepare to expand your mind and please don’t
worry if it all gets a little…
timey wimey.
Because SCP-2003 is the SCP Foundation’s
self-made time machine.
Even most of the staff at the SCP Foundation
itself don’t know about SCP-2003, given
the highly sensitive nature of the projects
surrounding it.
Much like SCP-2000 is a trump card securing
our present in the case of a catastrophic
XK-Class End of the World Scenario, SCP-2003
is our prophylactic for such a thing happening
in the foreseeable future.
What’s far more unique about SCP-2003 is
that the SCP Foundation created this ace in
the hole from scratch.
The SCP-2003 Time Machine was invented over
a 25 year period by reverse-engineering the
anomalous technology of three different classified
anomalies and retrofitting them into our own
non-anomalous framework.
The massive machine is housed in Armed Site
47, a remote and well-guarded facility disguised
as an oil refinery.
While extensive records of SCP-2003’s construction
have been made by the Foundation, and it stands
to reason that the machine could be reliably
and successfully reproduced in a different
context, even the most intelligent scientists
taking part in the project couldn’t explain
how or why it actually operates.
In the words of another mad inventor, “It
just works.”
The operating principles
of SCP-2003 are relatively
simple to understand: It is able to break
the laws of the space-time
continuum by immediately
transporting anything or anyone placed in
its central chamber to some point in the
chronological
future.
The subjects transported forwards will remain
in this future for several
months before instantaneously
being transported back to the exact location
they were standing in the future.
In order to prevent some kind of unfortunate
accident, like phasing back halfway through
a wall and becoming unpleasant modern art,
the Foundation has established a secure facility
for travelers to head and wait out the rest
of their time when their mission is complete.
Through extensive testing, including that
which was performed under the purview of Project
XN-SHEPHERD, the Foundation has discovered
a great deal about the nature of time travel
via SCP-2003.
We’ll outline the most crucial caveats here,
so what happens next makes a lot more sense
to you.
After all, if time travel was easy, everyone
would do it.
First, as we alluded to earlier, the data
collected by SCP-2003 on the nature of the
future is often unclear,
imprecise, and unreliable.
For example, the data collected from 2003
did prove extremely useful in predicting and
preventing a massive security breach over
at Site-19 in 1997.
So naturally, when it predicted a devastating
series of earthquakes off the West Coast of
the United States in 1999 - an event that
several agents sent through SCP-2003 observed
directly - it came as a shock to everyone
when nothing happened.
The Foundation discovered, following this,
that all predictions needed to be contextualized
through heaps of metadata for it to be of
any real use in predicting or preventing our
specific future.
The Foundation also discovered that certain
individuals had a strangely disproportionate
effect on the unfolding of future events.
Let’s say, for example, SCP-2003 discovers
that a new type of nuclear weapon will be
invented in 2028 and quickly adopted by a
number of leading nations by 2030.
And by 2035, tensions will rise, sabers will
rattle, and this nuclear weapon will be used
en masse to destroy human society as we know
it.
Naturally, in order to
prevent this, the Foundation
might see to it that certain groups of nuclear
scientists, certain generals, and certain
world leaders get liquidated.
And yet, another trip into the future shows
that this massive nuclear war was not averted.
But why?
Because, it just so happened that this event
was inexplicably tied to the birth of a little
boy named James Hoskins in Saskatoon circa
2025, despite little Jimmy Hoskins seemingly
having nothing to do with the actual development
of the technology - Seeing as he’s only
ten years old when the bombs start falling.
The Foundation scientists working under Project
XN-SHEPHERD keep a database of all of these
highly determinative individuals, also known
as Magnifier Individuals, so they can keep
tabs on how they’re affecting any future
timelines.
Speaking of future timelines, we’re afraid
to tell you that this penultimate caveat isn’t
exactly a pleasant one: There are few to any
cohesive future timelines where humanity survives
long term.
Bummer, right?
The Foundation calls these loose timelines
“Determinative Sets”, and in the majority
of them, human civilization collapses, all
humans die, and in some cases, the earth becomes
completely uninhabitable to all forms of life.
The Foundation is currently seeking a more
optimistic option through controlled manipulations
of the causal stream in our time, but currently,
all we have is the preferred option: Option
XN.
And if you’re someone who would jump at
the chance to travel into the future and take
a gander at all the wondrous or terrifying
sights, there’s actually one pretty major
caveat of SCP-2003 that we’ve been playing
rather close to the chest: Early Foundation
tests found out that the time travel process
via SCP-2003 is extremely damaging to plant
and animal tissue.
Rather than just going on a wacky time travel
adventure like Doctor Who or Austin Powers,
it’d be a little more like stepping into
a giant microwave while dressed in a spacesuit
made of aluminum foil: You’re gonna die
a horrible death.
But there is one silver lining - well, maybe
not “silver” from your perspective, probably
more like pewter - the Foundation has discovered
a way to viably send human-adjacent subjects
through time with SCP-2003 without instantaneous
death…
We just can’t promise that you’re going
to like it.
You see, the one kind of organic tissue that
seems to survive the SCP-2003 time travel
process is the human brain and nervous system.
Due to the highly controlled nature of Project
XN-SHEPHERD, the Foundation can’t just send
in D-Classes to do the job, they instead use
actual agents - though mostly ones who are
nearing or beyond retirement or are suffering
from a terminal illness.
These Agents are dosed on
a course of anti-anxiety,
anti-depressant, and antipsychotic chemotherapy
to toughen their minds for the horrors to
come.
Though the exact nature of these horrors is
kept secret from them until it’s already
happened.
You may be familiar with one of the Foundation’s
most well-known front companies: Boston Dynamics,
as well as one of their most famous products,
the robotic, quadrupedal probe known as BigDog.
Well, in order to send a sentient being through
time without them being completely destroyed
by SCP-2003, the agent’s brain and nervous
system are entirely removed from their body,
and transplanted into the body of a modified
BigDog.
Still think it’d be fun to time travel?
Hey, don’t look so nervous - For everyone
who agrees to be part of an SCP-2003 mission
and survives, you’ll get one hell of a pension.
Or, at least, your family will, if that’s
any consolation.
Now that you understand all this, let’s
come clean about this mysterious “Project
XN-SHEPHERD” we’ve been alluding to throughout
the video.
It all started with a letter to the heads
of the SCP-2003 research project from O5-7,
a member of the legendary O5 Council that
instructs the Foundation in all that it does.
The letter read:
“Up until this point, all attempts at future
intervention using SCP-2003 have been limited
in scope and scattershot in nature.
I have seen the wisdom in this approach; it
is informed by painstaking contingency planning
and risk/benefit evaluation.
The past 18 months of reports, however, have
promise if we are bold enough to seize the
initiative.
We may have found a way out, here.
The price, though.
There's always a price.
As you well know.
Consider this note an official change in policy.
As of today, all efforts at intervention are
now aimed at bringing about and preserving
XN.
Designated Magnifier Individuals associated
with XN are to be protected
from undue interference
at the expense of all other priorities.
In particular, Nuru Diagne must be allowed
to die in the manner most observations have
predicted for her.
If anything at all changes in that regard,
make it happen.
I trust that you're familiar enough with the
rest of the Determinative Sets to understand
why we're going this way.”
So, in short, of all the potential timelines,
O5-7 wants the researchers assigned to SCP-2003
to ensure that timeline XN is the one that
actually comes to be, seeing as it’s preferable
to the alternatives.
Hence, Project XN-SHEPHERD.
You’re probably wondering: What happens
in timeline XN that makes it the most desirable
outcome possible?
Well, things continue as normal.
Everything from anomalous activity to social
unrest to environmental factors stays pretty
much the same as time goes on, until 2349
when a giant, 22-kilometer asteroid strikes
the earth and wipes out the majority of humanity
in an instant.
Following this, the world becomes unfit for
human habitation.
Hey, don’t look so glum, you’ll all be
dead by then - Well, except Dr. Bright.
Sorry again, Jack.
We at least get a nice three centuries before
we’re wiped from the cosmic table.
Your next question is probably: If the preferred
option has humanity being wiped out by a giant
asteroid in a little over 300 years, what
are the other ones?
Aren’t we entitled to a multiple-choice
future if we don’t feel comfortable with
being completely annihilated by an asteroid
before we’re even halfway to the year 3000?
Well, we’ll give you a little tasting platter
of potential timelines, and you can take your
pick.
There was the narrowly avoided Scenario XB,
where things progressed in a similar fashion
to Scenario XN, except a massive gamma-ray
burst from the sun in April 2017 wiped out
all life on earth within 38 seconds.
Then there’s Scenario XE, where the birth
of an unnamed boy in Turkmenistan combined
with the election of Sir William Entwistle
as Prime Minister of New Zealand in 2049 leads
to a world-destroying nuclear exchange between
Israel and Greater Indonesia in 2058.
Any attempts to stop it just make it happen
sooner.
Or what about Scenario XH.
Here, a deadly, mutated form of influenza
causes the deaths of over a billion people
worldwide.
Combatting this threat
caused increased cooperation
between world governments that actually resulted
in a huge net improvement for global peace
and quality of life.
It seems unrealistic, we know, but SCP-2003
doesn’t lie.
However, despite things going well, all known
life on earth just vanishes on July 29th,
2059.
It’s a hell of an unpleasant twist after
things started going so well for once.
In Scenario XO, the anomalous increases in
frequency and magnitude in 2037.
This leads to a Broken Masquerade scenario
where the Foundation’s web of secrecy collapses,
and anomalous chaos reigns across the globe.
The Foundation’s members are hunted and
killed, and world governments attempting to
weaponize the anomalous leads to a new arms
race that wipes out all of humanity by 2048.
Or maybe Scenario XU is more your cup of tea.
In this one, the sun collapses, leading to
eternal darkness and massive temperature drops.
Inexplicably, humans still survive but are
in a state of constant, unmoving agony.
And maybe if you just really love spiders,
you’ll get a kick out of Scenario XX, where
a mysterious pathogenic protist causes the
majority of humanity to fall in love with
the Brazilian Wandering Spider - One of the
few spiders that pose an actual threat to
humans.
The diverting of all resources meant to keep
humans alive to instead breeding the spiders,
combined with many, many people being killed
by the resulting spiders, leads to six billion
deaths in the early 2030s.
But hey, you’ll get to see some pretty great
spiders, if that’s your thing, I guess.
Scenario XN is hardly a picnic.
Nobody likes the idea of facing an armageddon
straight out of Armageddon when that asteroid
kills all life on earth in 300 years.
But while it undeniably isn’t perfect, it
may just be the best option we’ve got.
Isn’t the future amazing?
Are you afraid of haunted houses? What
about haunted castles, or prisons,
or mental asylums? We’ve all seen or heard tales
of terrible, tortured souls walking down long and
lonely hallways, looking for people to pass their
ancient pain onto. But what about something a lot
more subtle. Perhaps as humble and unassuming
as a cozy little woodshed. An adventurer
named Cait would find that, sometimes,
terrible things hide in simple places.
With every step, twigs broke under the sole
of her boot, their snaps echoing around the
emptiness of the surrounding forest. Birds
cawed down at her from their perches up above,
a grave omen, a warning not to tread further…
well, at least to anyone who actually bought
into all that superstitious stuff. Cait was far
from a believer in that sort of thing, although,
at the same time, she had more than a passing
interest in all things occult and unnatural.
For her, it was less about the actual practice
of certain things, the appeal was more about
the stories that those practices inspired.
Legends and myths, spooky tales of ghosts,
or the dead rising from their graves and,
of course, the magical mother of them all:
witchcraft. Although her fascination with
the inexplicable and macabre rarely, if ever,
overlapped with her other big passion: hiking.
Until, of course, today.
She could trek anywhere and wanted to aim
for everywhere. Through sprawling national
parks filled with vibrant greenery, up the
sides of mountains climbing up to the peaks,
to across deserts, following the almost empty
highways to get from one tiny rural town to the
next. There was something about getting
to not just know about the world but to
actively go and see it with her own two eyes, to
actually be out there in it, that felt so right.
On her current journey, Cait had taken herself
on a long trail through the heart of the American
Midwest. Lugging a heavy pack over her shoulders,
filled with her tent, sleeping bag, outdoor
cooking supplies, and all manner of camping gear,
she had set off following the winding path of the
Patoka River, which ran around or adjacent to a
few of the major cities in the state of Indiana.
Cait was hoping to follow the flow of its main
body of water all the way through to the city
of Jasper. From there, it would be a straight
shot over to the similarly named Patoka Lake,
and after she had walked around the entire
circumference of that, it would be a long
hike East towards West Virginia, home of the
Blue Ridge Mountains. Sure, it was one hell of
an ambitious trip for one person traveling alone,
but Cait liked to keep her journeys unencumbered;
having someone else coming with her would just
slow her down, or they wouldn’t be able to keep up
with her at all. There’s no fun at all in that.
Stopping for the night, Cait lit herself a
campfire. She had to make sure to keep it far
enough from the trees to avoid starting any
potential catastrophes, but also not too close
to the wet bank of the Patoka, otherwise, her
kindling wouldn’t catch alight. There were so many
variables to consider for any aspiring camper.
Sparks from the flint that she always took on her
travels struck the dry twigs she had collected,
and soon, a gentle orange glow and wave of low
heat were radiating from it. The fire provided
Cait with just enough light to unfold and peg down
her tent as the diminishing visibility of the dusk
gave way to the encroaching nighttime darkness.
Before getting comfortable in her sleeping bag,
she put out her campfire using water from the
Patoka, then zipped up the front of her tent,
keeping a flimsy cloth barrier between herself
and the local wildlife. Not everyone found
it as easy to sleep in the woods as Cait did.
She couldn’t remember a time when the noise
of breaking twigs or the sounds of movement
outside had ever kept her awake. Even now,
the rustle of leaves and branches did little to
disturb her, regardless of whether it was just the
wind… or something else moving through the bushes.
Woken up by the sun rising, its warm light
breaking through the trees, Cait readied herself
to leave. She never stopped at the same place for
more than one night, and rarely slept for any
longer than she needed to. A nice, eight-hour
recharge of her energy reserves, and then it was
back to the open road. After a quick breakfast,
she packed up her single-person campsite, folded
up her tent, and stuffed it back into her bag.
Cait had been just about to leave when she
noticed something was missing. Her compass,
it had been in her backpack, which she kept in
the tent with her all night. Quickly scanning the
ground around her, she couldn’t see it. Weird, but
she figured she had obviously dropped it at some
point during her hike and would have to pick up a
new one when she got to Jasper. It didn’t matter,
she could just follow the Patoka River
as planned, although it didn’t quite
sit easily with her the rest of the day’s trek.
She’d packed the compass, that she was absolutely
certain of; after all, she knew it wasn’t
like her to leave it behind. But then again,
had she… could she have forgotten it entirely?
Over the next few hours, the question went round
and round in Cait’s head. As she walked along
the bank of the river, silently starting to
doubt herself, she drifted a little deeper into
the woods until, out of the corner of her eye,
she spotted something standing among the trees.
It wasn’t an animal or even a figure, but a
structure. Spending so much time out in nature,
anything man-made usually stuck out as an obvious,
unignorable eyesore to Cait. She looked at it
from a distance; it looked like an old house,
isolated out in the woods, a short walk from the
Patoka River. Checking the sky over her shoulder,
Cait noticed it was getting late again, the
daylight having gradually lowered while she’d
been wondering about why she had left her compass
behind… or if it had been taken. Deciding to set
up camp closer to the little house, she
turned and headed in to inspect it closer.
The place was far from the lap of modern
luxury. Not that Cait couldn’t live without
running water or electricity for long stints
of time. But it wasn’t a house that had been
built recently. Although she was no expert
in either archaeology or architecture, Cait
didn’t think anyone had lived there for decades,
possibly even centuries. It was almost medieval,
a single room that was completely ramshackle,
practically falling apart at the seams. Everywhere
she looked, the wood that had originally been
used to build it was either rotting away or
had been broken into splintered remains. Plants
from the forest had started growing through the
floors and the walls as if nature was trying
to reclaim this spot of land where someone had
once come to get away from the rest of the world.
Sighing, Cait shook her head as she looked at the
dilapidated house; there was no way even she could
sleep there. It was too much of a safety risk,
parts of the ceiling could easily fall on her
during the night if the wind picked up enough.
Turning to leave, she stopped in her tracks as
she noticed another structure, much smaller,
behind the house. It had been so dwarfed in
size by the slightly bigger building that it
was completely obscured from view. But it
looked to be in much better shape in terms
of its structural integrity. It was a woodshed,
its front door hanging lazily open. While not
exactly brand new by anyone’s standards, it was
at least far more intact than the main house.
Taking a few steps forward, Cait felt something
glass crunch under the heel of her boot. She
scanned the floor, instinctively checking for
any more so as not to injure herself. Even
with the low amount of sunlight fading ever
rapidly, it didn’t look like more. Kicking
her boot to loosen the shards, she made her
way towards the woodshed, not noticing that
what she’d been standing on had been a compass.
Reaching the shed, she peered inside. It was pitch
black within, almost as dark as the rest of the
forest would be in a few minutes. Taking off her
backpack and setting it down, she searched inside
for her flashlight. Retrieving it and flipping
the on switch, she looked back into the shed…
and that was when she saw it. Taking a step back,
Cait tripped over her bag, scrabbling back up
to her feet to make sure she had seen what she
thought she had. It was just lying there, still
and lifeless. For a split second, she had hoped it
was a trick of the light, just an old, decaying
lump of wood. But it wasn’t… it was a body.
The remains were charred, reduced to little more
than bones some time ago. Even the ground next to
it looked like it had been scorched, blackened
by some intense fire damage. Cait’s eyes were
so transfixed on the burned mass of bones that a
sudden sound startled her. Thunder growled above,
immediately telling her she had little choice
in what to do next. Her options were she
could either sleep outdoors and get drenched by
the rain, and possibly catch hypothermia from
being cold and wet. Or she could spend a night in
the cramped confines of this woodshed, which she
would have to share with a long dead body. Walking
back outside to retrieve her bag, she pulled out
a groundsheet and used it to cover up the bones.
It was a mostly sleepless night, and those were
a rarity for Cait. Any sleep she did get was
light, easily interrupted by as little as her
own movements, and offered her no actual rest.
But for the next few hours, she just lay awake
on the wooden floor. It wasn’t the sounds of rain
drumming against the shed’s ceiling or the booming
of thunderclaps that were keeping her awake.
Thoughts of what she was going to do about the
bones kept coming to the forefront of Cait’s mind,
should she report it to the police when she got to
Jasper? Was there even any point if she had no
idea where on the map this abandoned place was?
Frustrated, she tossed and turned, eventually
sitting up as something made a sound. It was a
low creaking, rusty metal hinge screeching for
a lack of any oiling over the years. The door
was open, swinging lazily in the decreasing
winds, its lock having long since broken.
Grumbling to herself, Cait reached for an old
shovel that had been left in the shed and went
to grab the open door. As her head poked out
from the shed, she looked around. It was the
middle of the night, nothing to be seen anywhere
around. Yet she couldn’t escape the feeling she
was being watched. Taking the shovel, she jammed
it underneath the doorframe, keeping it closed.
At last, there was quiet. Maybe now she’d be
able to get some much needed sleep, and she
did… but that’s when the nightmare started.
The dream was bizarre, unlike any Cait had
ever experienced before. She instantly recognized
the warm, flickering orange glow of a large fire
before her. Naturally, she started to pace her
way towards it, the fire’s heat washing over her
the closer she got. But as she approached,
Cait noticed something… moving amongst the
flames. Arms flailed, trying desperately
to extinguish the blaze, legs kicking and
writhing. And that was on top of the screaming.
Another figure was standing facing the bonfire,
their back to Cait as she walked closer still.
With every step, the sound of insects buzzing
could be heard, getting louder and louder. But it
wasn’t until she stepped near enough that she saw
where the noise was coming from. A swarm of bugs
was darting through the air, hovering around the
other figure; there were enough of the insects
that they formed what looked like a cloak, every
part of it moving and buzzing of its own accord.
The whole nightmare was so vivid, Cait had no idea
if it had been brought on by her exhaustion, or
that her mind was still fixated on the bones she’d
found in the woodshed, dehydration, lack of food,
or even some other influence. It could have been
any one of those factors that had caused her to
have a dream like this… or a combination of all of
them. Nonetheless, she could feel the bugs tapping
at her skin as she walked up to the other figure,
still unable to see them clearly. The noise of
insect wings whizzed past her ears, louder than
ever, loud enough to be real. Putting a hand on
the figure’s shoulder, Cait turned them around.
It was a woman, or what was left of her. She had
huge, gaping wounds left by something that had
been cruelly buried in her face, with similar
injuries lower down at her neck, and on her
chest. There were gaps in her skin, as if chunks
of her flesh had been hacked away. Yet somehow,
she was still standing, dead but also alive at the
same time. The swarm of bugs around her moved with
her body as she turned and faced Cait, a pair of
glassy eyes staring at her. They were both blank,
completely empty, each one missing its pupil.
Opening her mouth, the woman let out a piercing,
blood curdling shriek. All around her,
the sound of the bugs got louder, almost
deafening. And as she screamed… so did Cait.
Panting and shuddering, she sat bolt upright,
shock wracking her whole body, heart
thudding against her ribcage. Instantly,
the exact moment she woke up, Cait realized that
feeling was back. She had spent so much of her
time hiking through the woods on her own that
she could tell when someone was watching her.
In the dark, she fumbled for her flashlight,
and clicked it on to reveal… the door was still
jammed shut. Apart from her, there was no one
else inside the shed… no one alive, at least.
Looking over her shoulder, she could see the bones
behind her and immediately backed away from them;
as far as she could in the tiny wooden hut.
She had covered them before going to bed,
she was certain of it. Hadn’t she? All of
a sudden, Cait felt her skin start to itch,
an intense, irritating feeling. She had
experienced the effects of poison ivy and all
sorts of plants that cause similar reactions,
but this was easily a thousand times worse.
Her skin felt like it was burning; she scraped
her fingernails down her exposed arm, trying to
suppress the itching even for a moment but it
did nothing. She scratched at the other arm,
over and over again in one spot until her flesh
was pink and raw. Still no change. Cait raked her
nails over her own body, this time leaving a deep
scratch trailing over her arm. Under the light of
her torch, she realized that she’d drawn blood.
She looked back at the bones in the scorched
corner of the shed. The skull was facing
straight towards her, hollowed-out eye
sockets staring as empty as the pupilless eyes
of the woman in her nightmare. It had done this,
it must have done, she thought. Reaching
towards the door, dropping her flashlight,
she wrenched the shovel out from where she’d used
it to wedge the entrance closed. She stood up,
kicking her sleeping bag and backpack to the
side. As hard as she could, desperate to make the
itching stop, Cait brought the shovel downwards.
The head of it snapped the already weakened
floorboards of the shed, exposing the soft dry
earth beneath. Maybe if she buried those charred
remains, whatever was happening to her would stop.
Frantically, she started digging, hurling
shovelfuls of dirt out through the shed door.
It listed further open, creaking loudly on its
rusted hinges again, causing Cait to turn,
startled at the sound of it knocking against
the outer wall of the shed. Someone was looking
right at her, she could feel it as real and as
persistent as the itching feeling that crawled
over her skin like the tiny legs of an army of
insects. She dug further, eventually throwing
the shovel to one side and dragging her hands
through the exposed earth below, desperately
burrowing through and only stopping to use any
rocks she found to try and stop the itch.
All she achieved was drawing more blood.
Her fingers touched something soft, but solid,
and Cait brushed away to clear more of the
excess dirt, trying to uncover what it was. It
felt like a long mass just beneath the ground,
with a second similar object parallel to it. But
the further along with it she reached, the quicker
she realized what it was… a leg. Clearing more
of the dirt higher up, Cait could feel more. A
stomach, ribs, shoulders… and a head. Reaching for
her flashlight, buried under some of the dirt that
had been dug up, she pointed it at the thing she’d
found: the woman, the same one from the nightmare.
Something inside her chest moved, scratching
sharply, causing Cait to cough. And once she
started, she couldn’t stop. It was like the
itching she’d felt on the outside had now
worked its way inside and it was spreading… no,
moving. In fact, not just moving but crawling.
Through her lungs, burrowing down into her
stomach and, at the same time, upwards. The
clawing of tiny legs, digging their way up her
windpipe, blocking it. Cait couldn’t breathe,
she dropped to her knees retching as she
struggled for air, spluttering as she felt
something move at the back of her throat.
That was when she heard the buzzing again.
Locusts.
A swarm of them came spilling out
of Cait’s mouth. She couldn’t scream, let alone
catch her breath. They filled the shed in seconds,
engulfing her entire body as more and more of the
desert bugs still came pouring from her mouth.
Outside, the wind kicked up again, with
enough force to blow the door to the
woodshed closed again, trapping Cait inside as
the bugs tore at her. There was a single word on
the wooden surface of the door, written in deep,
black charcoal. She’d missed it, the door had been
open when she found the shed.
The word was ‘Witch’.
The SCP Foundation would later find this
cursed cabin, and would naturally lose a
number of D-Classes to a horrific form of
locust-based suffocation. While there are
clues as to what exactly is going on in this
terrible place - from the malice of a long dead
sorceress to the lingering revenge of a woman
wrongly persecuted - definitive answers as to
the anomalous mechanisms of the shed known as
SCP-4595 still elude even the Foundation’s finest
minds. It’s a place so mysterious and dangerous
that the special containment procedures read:
“For safety purposes, no personnel are
permitted to enter SCP-4595. SCP-4595
should only be entered by authorized testing
personnel under the supervision of the SCP-4595
research lead. Under no circumstances is
SCP-4595-A to be disturbed in any way.”
So perhaps we’ll never truly know why a
humble wooden shed in Jasper, Indiana,
causes such horrifying effects for its victims.
The SCP Foundation thinks it’s safer to just
lock it away and forget about it, letting
its ancient wood and old bones rot in the
dark. But if you really are curious about the
truth, you can always take a walk down the side
of the Patoka River and pay the Witch a visit.
If you’re lucky, you might even get to leave…
Step right up, folks! We’ve got all kinds
of refreshing and tasty treats here for
you today! Popcorn, peanuts, cotton
candy, and even fried dough! Yessiree,
here at SCP Explained, we’re
offering the top-of-the-line
anomalous delectable foodstuffs for all
of your circus-themed funtime occasions.
And that’s because today - Yes! Today! On
this Youtube Platform! - Our infamous acronym
doesn’t stand for Secure Contain Protect:
it stands for Sweet Confectionary Products.
And let me tell you, dear viewer, the
SCP we’re looking at today just might
be the most decadent, durable, and dangerous
dessert that’s ever desired to be devoured.
We’re talking about SCP-3077, or as
they are better known, The Sugar Golems!
These little fellas are Safe class and
also totally harmless - so long as you
take the proper precautions! What’s the matter,
don’t ya believe me? Don’t you think it’s
nice of us to cover a safe SCP now and again?
And hey now! Why all this dull talk about
rules and regulations in the first place?
You don’t go out to the carnival to not take
wild and exciting risks! Every spinny, twirly,
and whirly ride on the fairgrounds
comes with a statistically higher
chance of a tragic mishap befalling you
and any other thrill-seekers around you,
but we all take that chance anyway for
the extraordinary rush of the experience!
And such is the wacky and wonderful ways of
our adorable and questionably edible chums:
The Sugar Golems! Don’t you just love ‘em,
folks? Ain’t they a sight for sore eyes
and a pang for sweet teeth? Well, we’ve only
just gotten started! The best is yet to come,
ladies and non-ladies! So pull up a chair and
be sure to watch what we’ve got in store! You
can make like a piece of old candy and “stick
around!” Now that’s a knee-slapper, ain’t it? Sit
back, relax and make sure to enjoy the show!
You should also subscribe to SCP Explained if
you’d like to continue to be entertained. Hey,
that rhymed! Whaddaya know? I’m a poet,
and I didn’t even know it! How droll!
While SCP-3077 refers to the anomalous
substance contained in Site-81,
the semi-humanoid instances,
which are nicknamed sugar golems,
are themselves an animate and independent
by-product that naturally spawns from
SCP-3077 whenever it is allowed to
exist outside of containment procedures.
The most important of these containment procedures
being that SCP-3077 must remain at a constant
temperature of well below its freezing point and
only be stored in containers full to capacity,
lest its aforementioned by-products
attempt to breach containment. The
total volume of SCP-3077 within the cryogenic
containment unit equals almost 2280 liters,
and it is believed to be the only known quantity
of the anomalous substance in existence.
For the sake of clarity in distinguishing
between SCP-3077 and its byproducts,
we’ll be referring to the main object
contained by the Foundation as SCP-3077,
while the gooey little guys who we know to
spontaneously split off from the source of
SCP-3077 will be regarded as SCP-3077-1. As
mentioned before, SCP-3077-1 instances have
been affectionately dubbed The Sugar Golems. Every
instance of SCP-3077-1 resembles an approximately
one-meter tall gaunt humanoid composed of a pure
sugar-derived substance commonly known as treacle.
And that’s molasses for all of y’all -
yeehaw! - cowboys over there in the U S of A!
If you’ve ever played the classic board game
Candyland, you’ll have some idea of what an
individual instance of SCP-3077 looks like from
the beloved and often remembered character of
Gloppy, who lives in the molasses swamp section
of the board and is also fittingly made out of
molasses himself. Yes, indeed, Gloppy is truly
a delight for a weary CandyLand player to meet.
What did you say? Are you folks too young to know
about CandyLand? Well, that factoid certainly
makes this narrator feel pretty old. Then again,
I am taking on the mannerisms and attire of an
old-fashioned carnival barker, so I suppose a
bit of novel antiquity comes with the territory.
Regardless, the golems are each composed of
roughly 7 liters of sweet syrupy goodness,
and very much like everyone's favorite character
Gloppy they all lack defined lower bodies and
can all emote through crude yet oddly endearing
vocalizations in the place of intelligible speech.
While their facial features are simplistic
and misshapen, the contours of concave eyes
and a gaping mouth are usually present. The exact
number of these eyes and mouths is subject to
variation, much like the color of the board spaces
in a wonderful wholesome family game of CandyLand.
While every SCP-3077-1 instance is around the
same size, the body proportions and overall
shape of each instance are rather fluid - pun
fully intended! Some possess oversized arms or
bulbous heads, while others might be conjoined to
an adjacent sugar golem as if to show that the two
are as inseparable as a pair of best buddies. Or,
as some others might put it, a couple of B.F.F.F.s
- Best Friends for Fancy Frolicking. They
really are quite friendly-looking, aren’t they?
And aren’t they, they sure are! For the
only thing that these sugary sweet SCP
instances want is to be in the company
of human beings just like you. Yes,
you! Who else would I be talking to? It’s a hard
life for this worn-down carnie, let me tell ya!
These little sugar golems love what they do and do
what they love, but that doesn’t mean that it's a
time for fun and games! Even though SCP-3077-1
instances want to hang around human beings,
they don’t tend to stop at “hey” and “hello”
or whatever those appropriate greetings sound
like when they are being gurgled by a diminutive
molten sugar monster! Things can get out of hand
real fast - just like an orange cream popsicle
melting in the sun of a late summer’s day!
Now listen up, it’s important that you
pay attention to what I say next! I’m
about to book-learn you about what to
do if an instance of SCP-3077-1 enters
your personal space! The results of prolonged
contact with this SCP can end badly if you’re
not careful, much like a certain dessert that
contains the words “by chocolate” and nothing
good proceeding it! I’m not going to sugarcoat
any of the chewy details of your “gristly” fate,
and I promise you that it won’t be a
cakewalk, so don’t be a nerd and listen up!
Yes, that’s right, I called you a nerd. You know,
like nerds? The candy? How do you folks seriously
not know nerds? They were a classic Halloween
candy from the Wonka company and they were very
popular back in the day! Oh? What’s that you
say? How long ago was back in the day for me?
That’s a bit of a rude question, wouldn't
you say? Oooh…! Why I oughta…! Won’t you
go ahead and knock it off with the wise guy
questions! What are you, a pack of smarties?
Ha! I said Smarties! Get it?
It’s just like the—ah, nevermind.
Let’s just move on to the explanation
of how to survive a close encounter
with this SCP. That was the main
reason you came all the way to this
here educational and entertaining
video presentation, after all!
To pick up where I left off, instances
of SCP-3077-1 have a tendency to seek
out nearby human life. The reason for doing so is
surprisingly simple and alarmingly well… alarming!
These sticky saccharine simulacra are solely
set on slithering into people’s mouths for the
purpose of gaining total control of their bodies!
Yes, you heard that right! Believe it or not,
the same anomalous property which animates the
sugar golems’ treacle bodies is apparently capable
of overriding the human nervous system
from inside. And that’s no joke, folks!
While these tasty treats might sound sweet
to eat, you’ll be a puppet of meat from your
head to feet if you don’t complete the tasks I
entreat. If an instance of SCP-3077-1 attempts
to enter your mouth, you must remember first
and foremost to keep your trap shut - blocking
it with a mask or similar article of clothing
if need be! Next, you must use your limbs and
all available implements to batter the
attacking golem away while doing your
best to keep a distance of at least arm’s
reach between yourself and the instance.
It should come as a relief to all rational people
that SCP-3077-1 instances are severely limited in
their physical capabilities, and an adult human
of average fitness can easily hold one off if
they know what to expect. The tricky part comes
from the amorphous properties of the instances’
viscous treacle bodies, as well as their anomalous
ability to regenerate from any physical trauma.
The only way to permanently destroy an
instance of SCP-3077-1 is to expose it
to temperatures above its melting point
– which for you sticklers out there is
approximately 176 degrees celsius. The
most effective weapons against SCP-3077-1
instances include fire bombs, flamethrowers,
and your run-of-the-mill convection ovens.
If it is at all possible to contain the instance
within a sealed vessel such as a large Tupperware
or wooden barrel, then you oughta do whatever you
can to prevent the candy creeps from running amok.
While ordinary below-zero temperatures are unable
to destroy the anomalous treacle of SCP-3077,
instances of SCP-3077-1 can effectively be slowed
down or stopped completely if you put them on ice.
Whether it's the hot foot or the cold shoulder,
some form of extreme temperature should
always be weaponized when defending oneself
from an SCP-3077-1 instance. Any attempt to
crush or smash an SCP-3077-1 instance will
only result in the bad bonbon breaking apart
and reforming into several more belligerent
bite-sized blighters. A human under siege
by the sugar golems might find themselves
quickly outnumbered if they foolishly attempt
to use a melee weapon against the anomalies.
Basically, it’s like a more delicious version
of the popular arcade video game Asteroids!
No? Ehh. I guess that reference
was from even before my time.
At any rate, instances of SCP-3077-1 are
difficult to destroy without access to heat
or freezing. The tendency of the molasses
menaces to increase in number is made even
worse because of the fact that any amount of
SCP-3077 outside of containment can generate a
nearly infinite number of SCP-3077-1. While even
an army of SCP-3077-1 instances is far weaker
than an equivalent pack of hunting animals, the
ability to continuously multiply and physiology
that doesn’t experience the consequences
of fatigue means that given enough time,
the sugar golems can outlast any amount of human
resistance until they roll over their preferred
prey like a slow insurmountable syrupy tsunami of
surrender. Seriously scary stuff, some would say.
But what happens next is the real kicker,
folks! Mind this ballyhoo’s somber spiel!
If an instance of SCP-3077-1 manages to, against
all odds, clamber its way into a human chatterbox
and hijack the poor sap’s nervous system, the
victim is immediately classified as SCP-3077-2.
SCP-3077-2 instances are easily distinguished from
unaffected humans on sight alone. Dark tendrils of
SCP-3077 can be seen visibly moving beneath
the skin and often emerge from the mouth to
criss-cross the instance’s face like makeup,
the world’s most disturbing circus clown.
That’s not all! After the tragic treacly
transformation takes place, the movements
exhibited by the instance of SCP-3077-2 will
become crooked and jerky like a marionette
puppeteered by a frustrated chimpanzee! During
this time, the instance remains fully conscious,
retaining whatever cognitive faculties it
had possessed previous to its classification,
but it is unable to attempt speech or
exert autonomy over its own actions. This
fun fact was discovered by studying the EEG
recordings of several SCP-3077-2 instances,
and is brought to you by the United
Guild of the Existentially Terrified!
If an instance of SCP-3077-2 happens to wander
its way into the vicinity of any humans that
haven’t succumbed to the process of consuming
SCP-3077-1, it will proceed to put on a jaunty
performance for its newfound audience. This
peculiar display involves clumsy efforts at
dance choreography and the throaty singing of
unsettling atonal melodies that would make your
annoying cousin’s road trip songs sound like
they’re in tune. These awkward performances
continue until the audience departs from the
view of the SCP-3077-2 instance or the instance
expires. This confirms that the point of the
gesture is to entertain, as without an audience,
the SCP-3077-2 instance is not compelled
to make any noises of its own accord and,
in general, doesn’t do anything
other than move around aimlessly.
In the event that any number SCP-3077-1 instances
escapes from containment and cause the creation of
SCP-3077-2, members of the mobile task force are
instructed to never stray from the line of sight
of a currently performing SCP-3077-2 instance
and to approach steadily before restraining
the instance while causing minimal harm to
the body. SCP-3077-2 instances can be useful
for running further tests on the anomalous
properties of SCP-3077, and there are simple
procedures that allow an instance to be kept
alive indefinitely in containment. Any damage
sustained during capture can severely hamper the
efficiency of these life-sustaining procedures.
The worst-case scenario is that an SCP-3077-2
instance expires before being securely contained,
as this will cause the SCP-3077-1 instance to
emerge from its host and resume its relentless
attacks on all nearby humans. It is far easier to
simply deal with SCP-3077-2 instances accordingly,
and this is because SCP-3077-2 only ever
attempts to continue the performance and
possesses neither the intention
nor the capacity for retaliation.
If it is deemed necessary for the
effectiveness of a recapture effort,
it can be permissible for the Mobile Task
Force to allow instances of SCP-3077-1
outside of containing to find purchase
within SCP-3077-2 to increase the ease
of containment and lessen the risk of
Foundation personnel being affected.
The performances of SCP-3007-2
instances are rarely physically
intensive enough to make capture too
difficult, but it can be said that
the whimsical antics of these affected
humans are anything but predictable!
During some rare and special performances,
and if the SCP-3077-1 instance in control
of the SCP-3077-2 instance is feeling especially
daring - it may try to show off an array
of woefully inadequate acrobatic skills:
front flips that are more like belly flops,
back flips that could be mistaken for
pratfalls, and the sort of tightrope and
trapeze acts that are better left to the
imagination. In lieu of prior incidents,
The Foundation strongly advises that if
for any reason an instance of SCP-3077-2
must exist in containment, it must always be
prevented from being at an altitude of more
than six feet from the surface of the floor.
Especially if any humans it would perceive as
an audience are located directly beneath
where its performance would take place.
Regarding the creation of further instances
of SCP-3077-2, requests from any level of
Foundation personnel at Site-81 or elsewhere
must be granted permission to proceed by
SCP-3077’s head researcher. Because of
the horrific implications of what happens
to the still-aware human mind while the body is
affected by SCP-3077-1, this process is only to
be approved for use on D-class personnel. That’s
right! And even then - in the event that all the
rigamarole of the paperwork goes through,
it is not acceptable to create an instance
SCP-3077-2 merely for the purpose of providing
live entertainment to fellow researchers.
After all, not a single one of us should
be quick to forget the grotesque and
highly regrettable spectacle that was Dr.
Deitz’ Deplorable D-Class Dancers. Every
researcher involved with that ethical
nightmare was reprimanded severely,
and the colorful novelty costumes and jangling
bells that all former D-Class personnel were
made to wear after being reclassified to
SCP-3077-2 have been permanently confiscated.
Let the cotton candy machine and
peanut dispenser located just outside
the containment unit of SCP-3077 serve
as a stern reminder that there’s a time
and place for monkeyshines and tomfoolery, and
sometimes - yes, every now and then - a highly
secure Foundation facility is neither
the right place nor the right time.
In case you haven’t picked up on it, there are
very few practical applications of SCP-3077 due
to the fact that its status as a food dish is
negated by the consequences of consumption.
The main reason for tests to be administered on
SCP-3077-2 instances is to discover if there is
a safe method of extracting an SCP-3077-1
instance from the body of its host without
causing the expiration of the original
human. Unfortunately, due to a persistent
lack of success, these experiments have been
discontinued indefinitely. But that just won’t do!
How else are we supposed to know if these things
actually taste as good as they look? I won’t rest
until everyone is able to harmlessly ingest
a sugar golem of their very own! I might be
old-fashioned, but to me, the safe object class
isn’t just a designation, it’s an invitation!
I oughta be completely okay doing
whatever I like around a safe object,
because it’s safe! That word should actually
mean something - Ding dang darn it! And I
don’t mean in the sense that the SCP
Foundation uses it, meaning an anomaly
that doesn’t present an active threat to
containment efforts! And more importantly,
there aren’t that many anomalies that are also
delicious candy! And I want to eat this one!
Sorry, sorry, I lost my cool a bit
there… I just have such a sweet tooth,
and my brain is constantly drifting back to
my nostalgic childhood memories of playing
CandyLand with my family. That was before
they all decided that they wanted nothing
to do with me because I became so obsessed
with dressing up like a carnival barker that
I drove away everyone who ever cared about
me. Other than that, my job here at the
Foundation explaining confectionary SCPs
is the only thing I have left in my sad,
sad life. Some days I feel less like Gloppy,
and more like a real Lord Licorice. In hard
times such as these, a fellow could really
use some entertainment to cheer himself up.
Wait a flea-jumping moment! What is that? What’s
the big idea!? How did these escaped instances
of SCP 3077-2 get in here? They’re all supposed
to be safe in containment a few floors down. Did
somebody else from the research team let it in
here because they knew I was in costume standing
in front of a pretend fairground set? That’s in
pretty poor taste, don’t you think? Pun intended!
I should probably report to the head researcher…
That would be the ethical, reasonable thing to do…
Then again… look at ‘em all go! Those sure are
some hilarious dances! I’m definitely seeing a
snappy attempt at doing the Charleston - a classic
- and is that one doing the worm or… it is just
flopping on the floor? I think one of these
instances knows about that Fortnite stuff all the
kids are into these days, but I’m not sure if it’s
the human element or the golem that decides what
dances it knows. Either way, this was actually
exactly what I needed to feel so much better!
For once, it feels like I’m actually at a carnival
instead of just pretending to be at one! This is
the greatest performance I’ve ever seen in
all years - which you can be sure that there
have been a lot of! Until next time gents and
jolly strangers! I hope you enjoyed the show!
Just remember, the next time you’re hankering
for a snack - watch your back! Ha! Ha! Ha!
Now go check out “SCP-261 - Pan-Dimensional
Vending Machine” and “SCP-5962 - One Night
at McDonalds” for more anomalies
that’ll really whet your appetite!